Five four, three, two, one,
boom. And we're live. Mr Bisbing, how
are you sir? What's up Joe? I'm good.
Finally did this, man, I know if
it sounds good about it for years.
Feels like a lifetime. It's been quite
a while, man. Yeah, yeah. But yeah,
happy to be here.
Quite the setup you have as an Englishman.
Please explain to me the Hawaiian flag.
What the fuck is the Hawaiian vibe?
I'm like confused. I was looking at it
the other day when Max Holloway one.
I was like, if I didn't, if you didn't
know any better and you looked at that,
you'd like, this isn't some strange
flag by off the bar. I'm like,
girls are smart guy. I've seen the
podcast. He goes deep and I'm like,
do I need to reach some
encyclopedias before I come on here?
And the first thing you say is explain the
British flag. Sorry, the Hawaiian flag.
What is that?
Well,
it's like claim to be an expert
on the history of Hawaii.
I failed that class,
funnily enough.
But I would say that we kind of organized
it at one point much like America.
I don't know if you know this much,
like, you know you're going to Australia,
India,
Australia has got a funky flavor.
We like to insert the Union Jack in,
in lots of things.
And you think about the size of England,
how much of the world you guys kicked
ass on? It's pretty God damn impressive.
It really is. But again, I'm no
historian. No, but yeah, but no, it is.
I'm a proud Englishman. I guess our
ancestors were not my ancestors.
My ancestors are Polish and Irish. But
uh, but yeah, the British, they did okay.
Did a lot of shit, got a lot done or
they did. They did. You know, I was at a,
they get a lot of terrible things,
I'm sure over the years. But yeah,
I remember once I was in there in
Canada at a, at a party of all things,
about three o'clock in the morning
as well, you know, as one does.
And I walk in and some guy
starts going crazy at me.
The things that the British
have done over the years,
you should be ashamed of yourself.
And he was causing a huge scene,
really screaming at me. Right. And I
mean going crazy. And I'm like, dude,
what the fuck? Nothing to do with me is
that you should be ashamed. So in the end,
I said, well, where's your family from?
And you're not gonna believe this is,
he said Mongolian Germany. I'm
like, fuck you. You're a German,
you're German and you're giving
me shit about my heritage. Okay.
But I suggest you shut the fuck up.
That's pretty hilarious about the history.
The Germans way more reason.
Oh yeah. Just a little bit.
Just a little bit of English
stuff isn't the past. Come on.
It's like with swords and arrows and
Shag Robinhood towns. Come on, come on.
You know? Do you like living over here?
Yeah, very much so. You know what I mean?
Of course. You know, you miss, you
miss home, you miss friends and family.
Certainly. Um, you know, as you get older
and your parents get older, you know, you,
you do think about those things. But yeah,
it's great. It's great place to live.
You got to, your accent has
teamed it's Oh a bit. Well,
when you go back home to they give you
shit about it. I get shit all the time.
Yeah. All the time. And then like,
what's this weird accent, Mike? Um,
and he's like
this,
I'm intelligent enough to adapt to the
surroundings that I'm in. You know, a,
I'll now say tomatoes instead of tomato
because I don't want a cute little back
and forth to five minutes with the
fucking waitress. Do you know what I mean?
I just want to order my
breakfast. He called bomb with,
oh my God, you're English.
You know what I mean?
So I'll say tomorrow I'll say coffee,
but when I go back home, it
kind of, you know, and then
working on Fox, um, they did,
they worked on me for a while until
that Mike, we like what we think.
We like what you're saying. The problem
is we, I understand what you're saying.
It seems like it's good stuff.
There's lots of energy there, but, uh,
you to slow down while for pronounce
your words. So, uh, so yeah,
it is a little bastardized.
Have you thought about doing
commentary on UFC cards?
Have you done any of those yet?
I've just done the, what is it? The
content is here is that's it. Yeah,
that's it. But, but, but I think it's,
well, I know it well. It should be coming.
Ups just negotiated a deal for a child
with Zach, so yeah. That's good to hear.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, cause
you're really excellent as an analyst.
Well thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
Joy, your insight when you're on
the panel, that panel is great.
That that is one of the best things
UFC has done is do that post fight show
because when the fights are over, you
sitting around going, Fuck Holy Shit.
And then to have you guys break it down
and then break it down beforehand as
well, but break it down
afterwards. I really do enjoy that.
Well thank you very much. He had the
guys do a good job. Um, yeah, it's fun,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's nice to be involved with the
sport obviously as a martial artist,
as a fighter and then now
retired. He's still, you know,
still have a little hand in there
and it's, it's, it's nice. Yeah.
Made a smooth transition
from being a fighter to,
to retired seems at least from the
outside looking in that it seems fairly
smooth. It's like some guys have
a rocky road. It's hard for them.
Well it's because, um, you know, I mean,
I, I want to tell the truth while I'm on
here, so, so I will tell the truth, but,
you know, I had eye injuries,
you know, so, you know,
every form from when the eye
injuries happened in 2013,
I always felt like I was on borrowed time.
So I was conscious of trying to set myself
up outside of the octagon where a lot
of fires don't have that luxury. You know,
I'm thinking he could end at any mom.
And so I was
actively pursuing a life outside of the
octagon, a career outside the octagon.
So then when that day came, I
was good. You know, excuse me.
Some carbonated energy during
that shall remain nameless,
but, uh, but yeah, so, uh, so yeah, no, I,
I was working on that for a while and
yeah, you know, things are going well.
You know,
there's quite a lot of things going on.
So when you do that podcast with Louis
Gomez, got the podcast, believe you me,
I've got a company called play
lime. It's a a, it's a gambling.
It's fancy sports, but it's fancy
sports simplified. Basically.
It's kind of like a sports lottery.
So if we were focusing on the UFC,
who's going to win? What round? How
many take downs? We do five stars.
He hid them buying and
you've got $1 billion.
We had the analytics groups at Harvard
and Yale come up with a s a league.
So the top 50 people split
away everything. You've got
a billion and $1 billion.
One Ba ba boom, billion dollars, baby.
I'm gonna give away $1 million every
single day of play. land.com boom.
There it is. It is available in
our first year. It's blowing up.
It's blowing up big town.
We're just about to sign a deal with a
couple of major sports franchises to be
their official game. So, uh, so
that's going really well. Um,
so it's a essentially like a fantasy, a
martial arts thing. Like you just know it.
It's NASCAR, football, MMA.
The beauty of play land is you can set a
play land to anything and like we could
set a play land how many times he's
Bisping gonna burb how many times you're
going to get up and have
a pice of many tangents.
Rock are going to roll his eyes at Mike.
Do you know what I mean?
You can set it for anything. So he's
very applicable. Uh, how many times,
how many likes is Kim Kardashian
going to get in a next past?
You know what I mean? So it's um,
yeah, we're getting a lot of traction.
It's doing really, really well.
Very proud of it. I would think
if it's $1 billion,
I would think it'd be like some Guy
Ritchie movie where the sum mobsters would
get together with some fighters.
Yeah. This is how we're going
to do it. See, try and fix
it down three times. Yeah,
I've never heard it.
An English gangs to sound loud.
The from like 1920 Chicago she shoes.
This is what we're going to do. We'll see.
But yeah, I guess no is that
hasn't nobody's cheated yet.
But you know the reason why I say this
totally undermining the system, Joe,
really appreciate it. The reason why
I say this is because this happened
then with professional pool,
professional pool had a line at one point
in time in Vegas casinos and the pool
players all got together and said,
listen,
what's fucking put all our money on this
guy who was at the 10 to one favorite
to win it or tend to one underdog
to win it and we'll make money.
And so they all dumped in this one guy,
I think his name's Mike Lebron.
He won the whole thing.
The only way he could do that as
if there was no stats now stats.
So if it was game of basketball,
everyone would just have to stand
there and do nothing. Right.
Which I would assume. I mean, I don't
know too much about basketball, but I was,
I was Shem athletic commissions referees.
People getting,
somebody would say something if everyone
was just standing there doing nothing.
Well they did with pool. They can
gamble on porn anymore. Oh really?
Cool players are too shady. Yeah, they do.
They are. They are shady. The shady guys.
Anyone that plays pool in England, it's
because they spend so much time in pubs.
Exactly. He spent so
much time in pubs. Yeah.
Hanging out with some
interesting characters, you know,
unsavory characters. Dude, you,
you started at UFC ultimate
fighter season two. How crazy.
Three season three what? What season
to the end now or some shit. Like what?
What are they on? I think they
just did 28 28 but that's crazy.
But that's all in the US.
They have to the Brazilian one,
they have the Australian Diego
Sanchez and still fucking going at it.
That's what's insane. That's impressive.
Season One. He's a, he's a, God bless
him. You know, good for him. Good for
him. And he fucking one reasonably,
which is impressive. No, I know.
Any fights in a way that isn't
conducive to a long career? No,
but he's had one my word. It's
incredible. It really is. He really,
is he warrior such a fucking
character too. Oh Dude.
He's out of his mind in a
good way. I mean, you know,
I mean that's a compliment I do as well.
Yeah. Yeah. No, he's a maniac. But uh,
I mean Darcar season one and still
still going strong. I know, I know.
Crazy. Crazy. It's been a long
ride for myself as well, but uh,
enjoyed it and enjoyed every minute
of it. It was great. Nice to,
nice to leave everyone the title though,
right? Oh, 100%. How Nice is that?
The cap it off because you had
such a long career man. I mean,
you fought the best of the
best and for you to cap it off,
knocking out Luke Rockhold
and then having that, oh,
no one could take that away from you
for now. For sure. You know what I mean?
I was talking about this recently.
I'm filming a documentary called built
for this and it's about my career.
And they were asking about that, you
know, how would you feel? Excuse me.
This carbonating Eddie's drink shall
remain nameless energy drink and a cock
creature or something like that.
Creature Demon. Something lie.
That mythological, scary,
scary, scary monster.
There you go. Um, no, no. They
were asking about my fight career.
How would I have felt had I
not won the belt? And you know,
I mean, it would have felt like
it was unfinished business.
I wouldn't have been quiet as content
is walking away. When I did had a,
had I not won the belt,
other than winning the belt Wa and
winning the ultimate fighter, I'm sure.
But what was your most satisfying
victory? Was it Conley? No, no, no.
I don't know. I'm the most satisfying
victory. My word. Oh, Anderson Silva.
Anderson Silva. Yeah. That was a big one
for me. Yeah, that was a big one too,
because of the cheap knee. It was cheap.
It was, she said that it was cheap.
I mean, I'm a giant Anderson
Silva Fan. Yeah, everybody is.
You don't get any bigger
interest in a feeling than me,
but you didn't have your mouthpiece.
You were pointing to the mouth piece,
you were separated and you took a pause
and he thought the referee was going to
separate you and give
you back your mouthpiece.
And Anderson comes in with the
knee. Well, I know the rules.
There has to be a lull in the action
for the referee to step in, you know,
and I'm backing up and we're
not engaged in blows. To me,
that's a little in the action.
So I take that moment to point down
over here and say my mouthpiece,
and as I'm down there, boom, he throws
a beautiful knee. It was beautiful.
It really was good for him. You know,
I don't hold it against the guy.
It is what, it fucking came
back, eh. It wasn't fucking easy.
I'll tell you that.
Every part of my will to our continue.
But yeah,
you came back and won the next round.
That was what spectacularly
impressive. What, that's what you said.
What is the most satisfying? When I had
said that was one of them. Of course,
you know, beating Rockhold and
winning the belt. Nothing tops that.
But the big one too because you came
in on short notice as well. Sure, sure.
But the uh, yeah, the answer
one because of that, you know,
it just made the storyline
so much better, you know, to,
to fight through that
adversity to, um, you know,
I have to dig deep after winning it on,
you know,
I won the first drop Tim
drops when the second round,
third round I was winning then that
happened. So yeah, no, it felt good.
It felt good. Yeah. That was,
uh, I mean that also like to,
just to get a victory over that guy
when it all said and done. There's a,
there's some, yeah. Listen, I'm
aware of that. People would say, oh,
but you didn't get Anderson in his
prime. Well, maybe it was at his prime,
but with the amount of shit that I talked,
I certainly see a devil's in the way for
me to, the waste for recently. You know,
and it's funny because people always say
you don't worry that when you talk shit
gone into a fight that you got to
motivate your opponent even more.
And I always used to say, oh
no, don't be stupid. Listen,
they're gonna try and hit you as hard as
they can, but I don't know. And that one,
I think it did motivate Anderson cause
he was certainly not fucking about it and
that one, that's for sure. No you wasn't,
it wasn't like the Anderson in the Derek
Brunson fight, that's for sure. Yeah.
That was a different fight right there
in Brunson and him almost like looked him
in an agreement. They didn't fight.
Yeah. It was a weird fight. Yeah.
It's like we're,
Bronson didn't want to risk anything,
didn't want to engage with them too,
too quickly or go too hard.
But then you see some of his fights, he
comes at you like a fucking Marauder who?
Derek Pronto. Oh yeah, no, absolutely. Um,
I was talking about this recently with
the Israel ladder Sanya fight and I think
a kind of pissed Israel off
with a couple of my comments.
And that wasn't my intention. I
said, excuse me. I said, I'm not,
I don't know if I'm completely sold on
Israel yet. And what I meant by that,
I didn't mean sold on him being a great
fire because he's clearly a great face.
Clearly world class.
What I meant was sold on him being the
future of the division and being the
champion. That's what I meant, because
Brunson never showed up in that fight.
Right. And I mean, they were
the greatest of respect.
He was like a deer in the headlights,
you know, who he was intimidated.
It just been knocked out of Jack Era. You
know, I was a little gun shy, you know,
and it was a great performance. Israel
did what he needed to do. But as I say,
you know, it takes two to tango and
there was only Israel really fat.
And in that fact, so when I
said those comments, I said, ah,
I'm not entirely sold on that fight.
That's what I meant.
I didn't mean because I don't think he's
well class or excellent fire cause he
clearly is.
I just meant not sold on that fight.
Whether or not he's the
future of the division.
Well it's a stacked fucking
division. I mean, look,
you mean you still have your well
Romero at the top of the heap.
I don't know what they're doing with him.
I mean he was supposed to be fighting.
Uh, um, boy cina would, oh yeah,
pal. Acosta. Acosta, but her chine.
Yeah. Who's a fucking monster.
If anybody who's not on steroids
who looks like they're on steroids,
it's him and girl in the mirror.
Wow.
It's not that easy these days
with the siren. But come on.
Some of them are on steroids. Some of
them probably are Joe, but who's on?
Okay.
You're telling me that you don't believe
that Yoel Romero ever took a steroid in
his life? I didn't say that.
Okay. I definitely didn't
kill. I think it's possible.
It's totally possible. How's that
fence you're sitting on that I get hit?
It's a tough scenario for you to be it.
No, no, no. See commentary can honest Bro,
I believe that I'll say it and
let's not forget he tested positive.
There was that whole,
anytime somebody says it was a
taint or supplement is bullshit.
You never test the part as a friend.
Never tested positive in my life.
Let me tell you something.
I'm not a guy that scours the
back of everything I've read.
I'm a careless motherfucker. I
really am. I wish I wasn't, but I am.
I'll just go through my life doing what
I do. I've been tested a million times.
Never come close. Okay. Some of the
guys, they blow up the lab, you know,
there's no smoke without fire. You
know what I'm saying? I agree with you.
I agree with you. I remembered
there was talk years back, um,
before you saw that there was talk of
certain camps that would hire guys who
knew testing and these guys
would orchestrate a program
for these fighters to
make sure that they didn't get caught
right. They would figure out ways to,
you know, to taper off but
still keep your gains and,
and make sure that you
didn't test positive at all.
And this was done under the assumption
that everyone else was cheating as well.
And this was for a long time. That was
how a lot of people viewed the sport.
There was guys like you,
Bj Penn,
there was a few guys that you just
knew weren't going to do anything.
There was their word. They said they
were never going to do anything and,
and they never looked
like they did anything.
You always maintain the exact same
physique throughout your entire career.
What the thing is, I think where
they started getting a little weird,
and I don't want to bang on about
stowaways too much because that's been a
narrative that I've over. Yeah. You know,
I've said my piece about that. Right.
I don't want to, you know,
banging on about it too much,
but I think where the water's really
got America is when TRT came in,
testosterone replacement
therapy became a thing.
I know you had to do was go to the
doctor and said, hey, you know,
I can't get a hard on or whatever and
all of a sudden they sign you off or u of
t it. No, I know even worse,
you could take steroids first
and then come off of it.
So your testosterone was low.
They'll really go to a doctor and say,
I have low testosterone of course.
Yeah.
Because it messes up your
natural production of it.
Took steroids and then went in afterwards
and said they have low testosterone
because they were on steroids short.
Not Exactly.
So then it became legal and then you
had all these guys coming out of there
saying, you know, if I'm the
on TRT I'll die, I'll die.
And then the outlawed it and then 10 years
later some of them are still fighting
to this day. Yes. You know. So without
naming names, you know who you are.
Shame on you. You talked about
TRT Belcourt to your TV tour.
Belfort forever.
I mean that was when
he was on TRT.
He was a different kind of human being.
He was just completely different than
he is in either circumstance. Oh yeah.
Looking back you can say that.
I mean cause when I follow him,
I fought him on tit. You find him when
he was at the Super Victoria absolutely.
Look like fucking the incredible hulk.
He had butt muscles on his
fucking eyebrows. Yeah.
Looking back, you can see that,
you know, but, but at the time,
as a fighter, you gotta be,
you can't think like that. You know
what I mean? What are you looking at? Oh
yeah. That doesn't do it justice.
That's supposed to be before and after.
I'm just recovering from a cold or
the week. I'm a little congested,
so keep coughing. The real, the real
key. That's a better one. That's better.
That's way better.
That's much more accurate.
And he's a guy who was known
to take things. I mean,
he took things early in his
career. Remember when he
fought Randy when he was 19?
He was 240 pounds. Yeah, exactly.
His neck start at the top of
his head. Yeah. But Sam, yeah,
I remember there was a picture of us
both on the scale in Brazil and, uh,
you know, looking back now a holy
shit, you know, anyone else would,
they have seen these guys kind of
big blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But you're not think like that at
the time. You can't, as a fighter,
if you start having those thoughts,
those doubts shut looking at fighters
physique and thinking, oh, he looks good.
You've already lost. You
know. But in hindsight,
you can look back at your holy
fuck, what was I thinking? You know,
this guy's fucking birdied out
of his mind. I remember on the,
I was trying to get a rise out of him
and he kept putting his hand in my face.
I'm not a religious guy and, and you know,
God bless anyone that is, you know, I,
I mean that, I respect
everyone's opinions, but I'm not.
And as we now veto is heavily religious
and he kept sticking in his thing in my
face. He was pissing me off. So I
said, Peter, come here, come here.
And he leans down. I said,
Dooley's no, Jesus, mate.
Maybe there is, maybe there is, you know,
me getting their jobs with a
head kick in the second round.
Maybe that was God thwarting
May, who knows? What did he say?
Some fucking Portuguese bullshit.
I don't know.
There's, there is the fine line
though, between target shit and uh,
and backing it up. But
you don't, you, you,
you did a great job of pissing people
off in your career. And that is,
that plays a factor that whatever you
can do to get just them a little bit out
of their comfort zone, a little bit
out of their composure. I, and you,
you were really good at that. Yeah. You're
not, you know, I mean, I hate that to be,
uh, you know, the first thing that
people say about me, but you know,
what's one, it wasn't a, it
was a thing, you know, it was
what I did. And in my mind,
you know, where I come from,
my background, you know,
if we're going to fight,
then we're going to fight and
then it's all out war, you know?
And until it's all said and done. And if
I can make you doubt yourself, if I can,
you know,
it's like at the wains at the ways,
that's the last time you're going to
get a chance to stand in front of your
opponent and send a message to him.
You know what I mean?
And if you get in his face and you can
just instill a little fear, puffy chest,
that's why animals do it in the wild.
You know what I mean? Puffy chest out,
look intimidating, look as
angry as you can, you know? And,
and some fires might just look
at that and laugh and said,
this ain't going to work on me,
but some it does. And, and then,
and then they don't fight to the best of
their ability because they're slightly
doubting themselves and they're not
fully committed to the punch or the kick.
And if they're not fully committed,
they're not 100%.
They're not fighting as well as they
can be. And I'm winning that battle,
you know?
So yeah,
you look like kind of a thug standing
up there and pointing your finger and
talking shit. But it's for a
reason, you know, it works. Yeah.
And those Mcgregor Mcgregor is
the best at it, you know. Yeah.
It gets people to fold.
Look at Dustin Poirier. Yay.
Didn't even show up in that first fight.
It's true. Yeah. He, yeah, he, I mean,
don't get me wrong. He was great as well.
You know, it wasn't just the trash dot.
No, he's great as well. I think
the Nate Diaz fight didn't,
it didn't work in that fight. Nate
doesn't give a fuck. Doesn't give a fuck.
There you go. It doesn't work.
Exactly. It doesn't work.
We touch shit at him and he's
like, fuck you. It doesn't, yeah.
It doesn't make him feel bad at all.
He, it didn't exactly feel comforting.
Yeah. Well, you know, just another
day at the office, you know, it's a,
it's a thing like a lot of people would
wish that fighters were respectful and
just, you know, treat it well, the
martial arts way and bow to each other.
And that's great. It is.
You know, it's funny,
I was working out this morning and the gym
manager, uh, he said, he said, you know,
actually I feel that that side
of things can have, you know,
it's killing the UFC and I shut
the fuck up. I'm like, you know,
I nodded away and like, you
know, respectful to the guy. Um,
but I, I see his point, I
understand what he's saying,
but it's entertainment
and it gets people that,
that's another reason why I used to do it.
You're trying to sell the fight.
You know, you want, you want,
you want every product you're involved
with to be as popular as possible.
Whether it's a podcast, whether it's
fighting, whether it's whatever it is.
If no one's watching,
no one gives a fuck,
then you're not going to make much money.
You're not going to get booked again.
You're not going to be on the big cards.
So you talk a little,
I know from a consumer standpoint,
if I'm watching a fight, I mean,
look at that last week with their
fury and wilder, you know, I was,
I was eating at the palm of their hands.
It was an amazing fight. But um, you know,
it hypes it. It's great. It's
awesome to watch. I mean, yes,
it is beautiful to see two fires walk
up there and bow and shake hands and all
the rest of it.
But it's also a little fucking boring
if I'm honest lot when I'm working the
ways yards, I'm like give me something
to talk about please. You know,
cause I don't want to talk
about your boy and last bite,
they went to a split decision and we're,
nothing really happened.
But if you get in their
face at the way him, great.
We can pump it up a little bit. We can
sell the fight. We can hype it up. Yeah.
When they have these press conferences
and no one's being mean at all. I mean,
half the funds shit. Yeah, no, absolutely.
Do you know, I'm enjoying myself.
I'm in my element of
there. It's like, you know,
the famous one with GSP when his
IRA, you intoxicate dead. Well,
yeah.
Well Yeah,
I'm in Vegas. Where do you
want me to do? You know,
you don't want to fight until the end
of the year and it's January. Okay.
If we were fighting in two
months, I wouldn't be in
toxic gay did for right now.
I am. You know, so, yeah. Well,
there's been some hilarious moments
in press conferences. I mean, the,
the one that giant one with the UFC were,
uh,
Jeremy Stephens out the
Connor fuck is that,
that was hilarious. That was great.
It really was good. It honestly,
every time I see that, I do laugh.
It was great. He had to say was,
is that guy?
But I don't know.
But I think he was
actually actually serious.
Is this guy calling me out talking shit?
Or he knows who Jeremy Stevens.
Just know. You don't think so? Maybe.
Maybe, maybe. Maybe not. Maybe not.
I don't know everybody up there sometimes
at press conferences. Yeah. You can't.
You know what I mean? Do you have see has
more than 500 fighters on their roster.
Exactly. Especially when they have those
giant press conferences and there's,
yeah. Need levels of design. 16
fires up there. It's impossible.
I like both.
I like when fighters are respectful and
I like when fighters talk shit. Yeah,
for sure. I mean, I did enjoy, it was nice
to see. Yeah. Brian Ortega. Max Holloway.
They had that nice back and
forth where Max, sorry. Pardon
me. Brian was, you know,
he's like,
listen,
I hope you're well and a hobby or over
the injuries and all that type of thing.
That was nice to seems great,
but they both were exuding
confidence at the same time.
They were both adamant they were going
to win the fight. So it wasn't the,
they weren't being too overly cordio.
Yes. You know, I don't want to see that.
Right, right. I don't want to,
I don't want to see too fast pretending
like they were in church or meeting the
fucking president.
Okay.
I want to see two guys that want
to rip each other's heads off.
Call me an animal, call me a bad
parent. Call me whatever you want.
But that's what gets my engine taken.
Well,
even when they were at the final weigh
in and they're staring each other down,
like even though it was respectful,
there was a lot of tension.
There's a lot of tension. You, you know,
you're talking about as a way in. Yeah.
I never saw that one when they were at
the way in Maxim Brown, they just stood,
you know,
a couple of feet away from each other
staring at each other and it was intense.
It was real. There was a fucking
hell of a fight to ballsy shit.
He's incredible. He really
is. Really is. I mean,
I was kind of um,
not concerned and of course were the
one who initially throw up the red flag
when you saw, you just felt like
he looked too tired or lazy.
Slurring his words. He
looked, he looked half asleep.
He looked like he just got out of bed.
That's how we looked.
And then he was slurring his words. And
then, so I just said, your care Max,
everything good. And he's just like, know.
Yeah, he was slowing it. Simple as that.
And I'm like, and of course UFC
tonight you have a production meeting,
we go over the questions,
we're gonna ask.
So you've got them questions there
in front of you. And I thought,
I can't stick to these questions. I've got
to ask this guy. Are you okay? You know,
for you. I'm glad you
did that. Well, you know,
I felt bad afterwards because then
I heard that the fire was off.
And then I thought, shit, if
I'd gone on, you know, two days,
three days out from a five I got on
fucking UFC tonight, or whatever,
you're doing my obligations as a fire.
And then another fire on the roster
is calling me out for an injury.
And now the fight itself,
I'd have been pissed off with them.
You know what I mean?
Maybe you know that that's my
choice if I want to highlight it.
So I felt a little bad, but
I really respect him. Max,
he sent me a message thanking
me, you know, he said, thank
you. He said, you know,
he said, uh, I appreciate that I needed
someone to do that because he knew he was,
he wasn't 100%. Um, so yeah, so anyway,
I will say that I wasn't fully
convinced that he was okay.
Cause it seemed like he was not an os
still slow in his words or whatever,
but a mumbler he's a mumbler.
Yeah. So am I, you know, so,
uh, he's, uh, he was fine though.
He was more than fine, dude.
He looked insane.
Insane.
Ortega fired back or
three shots third round,
hit him a couple of big shots and then
at the end of the third round he's like,
this is my right. No, I saw him and I
told you. Yeah, it's crazy. It's crazy.
And Cardio Cardio is incredible
to the roof, you know. Excellent.
Footwork combinations could
Sangha as well. Weeds the fight.
That's the main thing. You know what
I mean? He reads the fight, so yeah,
he reads the fine and he's,
he's,
he's so good at implementing that
strategy of like consistent pressure,
constant angles,
switching stances.
And he switched his stamps as flawlessly
fights. Just as good south paws.
It does Orthodox and he'll switch in the
middle of a combination and then turn
corners on. Absolutely. That's right.
He's not there to be counted. Yeah.
Not An amazing man. Really good. And when
you hit him back you look claps. Yeah,
no for sure. It gets recorded. Alarmists
and he just pointed at the floor.
He's like, come on, let's go right here.
That's that. And then bang it out. Yeah.
He's a wise all soccer. That was
awesome. Really was, you know, it's,
it's great to see that he is okay too.
But I'm really happy that you did point
that out because there was some issues
and I think a lot of that probably
had to do, I'm just speculating,
but probably had to do with
that massive weight cut.
I mean he was trying to get down really
quickly to one 55 which is crazy. Right.
Cause he fights at one 45 is the champion.
And even struggling to go down from him
that he was in the one eighties get down
to one 55 quickly to find that it can be.
Yeah,
because they offered it to
him on last minute. Sure.
You know when Tony tore his knee apart,
was that on set with you guys? Well,
you wasn't there. I wasn't there now,
but yeah, it was in studios. Yeah.
What a fucking freak occurrence.
That was crazy.
Trips over some wires blows
his knee apart. What was it?
The fire had been matched three times.
Yeah. And then they're all most of that.
That the finish line doing the final
bit of press. Yeah. It's crazy.
It's insane.
You can such bad luck.
It's like those guys are destined to
never fight. Oh, they've got to fight now.
I would if I was the,
if I could wave a wand in any
match I want not division.
That's the one that's the
match. Oh, for sure. Well,
it's the fight that has to happen.
You know what I mean?
Tony is, uh, in my, my
still the interim champion.
Knowing your why, the Triptan, it doesn't
make any sense to me. Listen, Tony's,
you know, he's a, he's a,
he's a character, shall we
say. Yeah. He's a character.
He's a unique character, but he, in my
mind, he fought for the interim title.
He won the interim title and then he
fucking blew his knee out, you know,
doing press obligations. It didn't
do anything stupid. No, exactly.
That's why I didn't understand that they
stripped him and I was like, this guy,
I mean the guy's ready to fight then and
then a few months later he was ready to
go again. He beats the shit
out of Pedis. Yeah, no noise.
And he looked incredible jobs kind of
concerned in that fight as well because it
was so fast coming knock and I've so
fast and apparently he was doing his own
rehab, these wild techniques and you
saw that stuff online that he was doing.
I thought this guy is going
to hurt himself again. But
uh, now he went out there,
looked amazing. You didn't even do any
sparring. Oh really? Yeah. Interesting.
I need to find this out for sure for him.
But the word I'm getting for people
that know him and said he didn't spar,
he just got an incredible shape and he
said, look, this knee is healing up.
It's in the process of healing.
And during his camp it was continuing
to heal and they chased him the way he
kept that going. I don't do any take
downs. Don't get your knee wrench,
don't get leg kicked. Well spine is the
hardest part of preparing for a fire.
Of course, you know. Well and the
wrestling, wrestling, inspiring. They're,
they're the toughest probably
wrestling grantees actually.
But find a wrestler doesn't have fucked
up knees. Yeah, my knees are fuck.
Not that I'm arrested far from it,
but my knees are just destroyed.
The stress gets mostly,
well I think I have a torn meniscus on
my good knee right now cause that's not
good knee. But my bad knee, um, I
actually GSP the son of a bitch,
he caused it back here.
I was training for the ultimate fighter
three final and it was trending with
George and we were training, you know,
zoo for the old Jew for headquarters.
They've done little gym at the
bottom with the boxing ring. Yeah.
We were wrestling in there and then
my knee hit the floor, tore my PCL,
and then just one thing after the
other, you know, that was what,
1312 years ago. And it's just
always been kind of fucked. Yeah.
Well actually in here right now,
when we finished out,
when I stand a limp like crazy,
because when I sit here like this,
it just seizes up like crazy. So if
I'm in a restaurant, let's stand up.
And I walked like a moron.
If I wanted the bathroom,
it was like fucking look at this guy,
Jesus grass.
But then I walked back and I'm walking in,
find the light,
this attention seeking bastard.
Forgot that he put on a fake Linwood.
He went to the bathroom. I'm like,
no, it's unseized now. It's okay.
It's just when I first stand up.
Yeah. Uh, the popliteal cyst.
I think that's what causing
that right now. So there's
a system there? I think so.
Yeah. Well, no, it's rained. Yeah,
no, I know this on my right knee.
I've had them drink twice. Yeah, I've got
to get that done. It's a pain in the ass.
Yeah,
it is.
The last time they just went in there
and just pulverized it went in there and
just kept sticking it with
needles. Rarely. Yeah. Yeah.
I've got to get it done.
I've got to get that. I got to get
a lot of shit. Does my neck issue,
remember we talking years
ago in Manchester about
[inaudible] and people didn't
know,
but what I mean it was hard for me to
talk about it any more to talk about too
much while I was commentating.
Your fights, you had a neck
injury that was so bad.
One of your arms was weaker than the
other, like if you were doing bench press.
Oh for sure. Still to this
day. I mean you could,
you could take that Samurai sword.
I don't advise it and stick it through
the skin there and I wouldn't feel a
thing. Well, I don't know if I wouldn't
feel a thing, but I'm totally numb.
Totally in a Maya.
I had a shower after my workout before
and now what a gala I get lied to.
It's like a a singer. Yeah. But Dan, the
entire buying side, it was in the shower.
I was there. It's having, the few
times when I've been working on TV,
I was doing this show called hyper drive
for Netflix in the summer and we will,
we will,
it was night shoots is that four in the
morning and all of a sudden I'm doing
this and everyone's like, oh my God.
Oh. I'm like, it's okay. Calm down.
They're like medic. I'm like, no, it's
okay. It happens all the time. So yeah,
it's just pinched nerve, you know, c five
c six, I gotta get it taken care of. Um,
have you ever done any decompression
or anything like that? Um,
it's all my own fault. You
know, I'm too old school.
I need to go in and have treatment
on my body, but it's like,
it's a whole thing. Joe
Casey, I'm a busy man.
I haven't got an afternoon
to golf sit and you know,
get Masyado decompressed or I need to
do it. I need to do it. And this year,
2019 is a year that I
get all these little,
because my quality of life is still
fine. You know what I mean? I just,
I just grin and bear it and whatever
and just occasionally have a mini heart
attack, you know, I'll be okay, I'm fine.
But eventually,
this is the year I'm gonna get all
these little niggles taken care of.
Well there's a company in Santa Monica
called lifespan medicine and they do a
procedure called Regena keen and that's
what Peyton manning had done over in
Germany. Come. Brian had it done.
And this is how I fixed my
bulging disc in my neck. Well,
when I saw you there in Manchester,
Dana tried to send me to Germany. Yes.
And I was telling you, you don't have
to go to Germany. Yeah, yeah, they do.
It's exactly the same procedure. I
didn't go to Germany, go to Durham,
that couldn't be bothered.
I didn't want to go down and spend
a half an hour or half of my day.
I don't want to fly to fucking Germany
and giving you a week or whatever.
So not that much time.
It'll take you like a couple hours.
You do it three or four times and they
can fix it. Now I know inflammation.
The other thing is there's a
thing that they sell at Amazon.
You just get on an amazon.com or a
bunch of other stores online and it's a
spinal decompression harness.
I've seen it hanging on the door.
Have you seen the thing where you use
their, you pump your hand. That one too.
I thought that's what you were talking
about that. That's a good one too.
I haven't used that one, but I have
friends that have used that one.
They like it a lot. It's
not bad. It's not bad.
The one that I use your hang from a door.
It's a little more hardcore.
It's hooked up to this harness. It clips
at the top of the door and you crank it.
Click, click, click, click, click, click,
click, and you're like literally hanging.
You're hanging in there. I was
going to say chair, but it just, Oh,
when you get out of, yeah. Good. I'm
going to try and get one of those.
If you do it consistently,
it'll decompress. Rarely
do that. I need to do that.
Yeah, you can do it in your house just
to get up in the morning, you know,
have you come, a wife comes and finds me.
Hang on. I couldn't make it to suicide,
but that dangling from the fucking
doorframe thanks Joelle won't kill you.
It won't kill it now.
But it's um,
it does mean it does feel good and
it's the only way that I know of,
to really stretch your neck out that
way. Yeah. No, I do need to do that.
I try and do it in the sauna. Was it
rustling the, did your yeah, for sure.
For sure. Yeah. In fact, I remember it.
I was going for a take down and I
think I ended up headbutting the floor.
A lot of it. What happened, there was
one of the fighters from Alpha Male,
he shot in for a take down. The guy
went for a good team. Uh, and he,
he spiked himself. Right. And then
just never walk. Never walked.
He never walked home while came paralyzed.
No Way. Yeah. Cause as he shot, you know,
he went and deep on the armpit,
the guy went for the guillotine so his
head is trapped and all their weights
together, you know, feet up
in the air. The whole deal.
Power, power double. Yeah, no,
of course. Yeah. And then you've
got two body weights. Yup.
Go on to head and neck as, as the, uh,
you know, the pressure point if you will.
It Derrick Lewis who has the
funniest Instagram of all
time for sure. Absolutely.
One on yesterday of a girl.
I think she's dead.
She twerked and she twerked standing on
her head and then she twisted her neck
and then her whole body seized up. Stiff
as a board. But I'm glad you would Derek.
Finding funny.
I'm sure this poor woman's families,
I hope she's okay. Yeah. Yeah,
I do. I hope she's okay as well.
But, but you know, if she's not, there's
nothing to do about it now. Well No,
the visit now, maybe we want take
the piss out of it. It's got to,
you got to look at Derek's Instagram
on a daily basis because a lot of this
stuff gets taken down.
Oh, really? Yeah. Yeah.
I'm surprised he hasn't been banned yet.
You know, he's too popular now a lot.
Derrick, for a while. He's
awesome. He's, he's talking,
you'll get areas he doesn't give a damn.
No. Doesn't care. That's the thing.
I see things. People send me things,
you know, guys from back home,
I got some things this morning, you
know, put the massively offensive right.
You know,
and having a little chuckle in private.
I'm not going to put
that shit on Instagram.
I'm not going to put it for the
whole world to see. What is this?
Is it doing a movie or something?
He's doing a movie, I think,
but then I think somebody
the other day I said, uh,
when John John's sneezes on.
Yeah, I saw some of that caption.
Oh,
Jon Jones.
He's an interesting character,
huh? Oh yeah. Yeah. For sure.
The big comeback is going to be a
tough fight, man. That's a big fight.
That's a big Gustafson is no joke.
The way that I love the way they,
they size up to the way they
match up against you. See,
maybe that's why John's struggled a
little bit the first time because he's not
used to fight in somebody
with the same frame,
the same physical attributes and
make John sold. Great. Alex also.
Yes.
And what was his last five?
Was it, uh, to sharer?
I think it was amazing in that fight.
It's handled so fast,
so fast. The combinations he put
together there were beautiful, really,
really good. The final Kao was like
a video game sequence. Oh Dude.
It was incredible. It really
was. It really was. I mean,
I think in a lot of ways that was like
what we're looking at with Tyson fury and
Deontay wilder,
like two guys would never fought
anybody that size before the for sure.
Both fighting giants, both fighting is tar
guys. Well, I know you had both guys on,
on the show and a listen to a little bit
of yesterday's with Deontae when I was
picking my son up from wrestling.
Um, but when I watched that fight,
I sorry, not when I watched it
prior to the fire happening,
I thought [inaudible] was
going to win. Okay. Um,
even though titans are very, very good
technical box and for such a big man,
use a lot of faints and a lot of
misdirection and he's very good. Um,
I thought the answer is
probably going to catch him,
but then when I saw that he weighed
in at 212 pounds, I said, it's over.
There's no way. 212 pounds. It's too much
of a weight disparity. It's, it's insane.
But uh, yeah, still got that
knock out power man. Unbelievable.
Another one when he got into the ring.
Yeah, I heard you saying that to or nine.
Yeah. As a fucking heavyweight. It's
insane. Well, that's what I thought.
I thought this guy is too light.
He's like his twig.
The six foot seven two oh nine
crazy. It's crazy. It really is.
I have fucking 12th round Kao or the Kale,
the knockdown.
That was insane. It really was. He's got
like Teddy Atlas said it best. He goes,
he's like fucking sore
with their hammer. But, uh,
I mean all respect and credit to task
and fury. Forget now, fuck. I mean,
I know there was all that talk and
Deontae put it on his Instagram about it.
Not actually been 10 seconds
about it being over 10 seconds,
but still it is what it is tied to
be over 10 seconds on the clock.
But the referee,
it's not the fighters job
knowing he's his job to,
to monitor. I stopped watching the corner
and say, Hey, breath breath, we're at 10.
No, he hasn't said 10 and he
gets up fight still on, you know,
there's no telling that he couldn't
have got up on the actual 10.
He probably could have gone up, but
the actual common tenants, well,
but just the way he got up and
then managed to win the round.
Well that's what really impressed me.
I wasn't the biggest fan of
Tyson fury a few years ago. Uh,
he, he, I don't know, we had some
stupid back and forth on a, uh,
on social media, on Twitter. But, uh,
what was it about [inaudible]
he was saying that some gypsy,
John, whoever, he is knocked me out
Saturday night club in Blackburn,
but the only problem with
that is a supposedly at the
time when I was living in
America. So anyway, so,
so it didn't happen.
I've never been knocked out
at a nightclub in my life,
but apparently according
to Tyson it did happen.
So I wasn't overly thrilled,
but I've got to say
over the last six months
or even a year, you know, he really,
really won me over what he overcame
illusion or that way going through that
depression or a slump,
whatever you want to call it.
And then coming back and looking so
good. And then afterwards, you know,
the post fight speech I
thought was beautiful. Um,
donating all of his money to
charity, all of it. It's just insane.
I mean 10 million,
you can't respect that then that,
then you've got a serious problem size.
So,
so I applaud the guy and I'm a huge fan.
Yeah.
I respect the shit out of both of them.
And I think that what happened with
you was during his cocaine days,
so was coked up and
drinking like a fucking,
probably probably out of his
mind. He said, yeah, yeah,
exactly. Who Cares? Who Cares?
He went through a dark time.
But you know what's fascinating to me is
that he pulled himself out of it and I
just pulled themselves out. But I want
to pull other people out too. Sure. No,
absolutely. I, and again, you know,
donating all that harder and money hi.
And you know,
you could have just given a million.
Yeah. And would be, I never would
have thought that was amazing as well.
That would have been a huge PR
stuff. But no, he gave it all. And,
and that speaks volumes about the man.
I mean, he even said, I don't need it.
You know, he's a gypsy.
He doesn't need it.
He's probably made enough money to retire
already. He's had some big fights. Sure.
And close our fight and, and the,
the rematch will be even bigger. Oh,
the rematch can then be
gigantic. The talking about it
somewhere, April, May, June,
somewhere around there. Yeah. Yeah.
That's going to be fucking saying. Yeah.
One of the best boxing fights
I've ever seen me as well.
It really was incredible.
Like it was it w it looked like titan
was out boxing them and you know,
using a lot of faints,
a lot of movement,
a lot of misdirection and a lot of let
that Herky jerky style then that's what
he does.
That's how it confuses people.
But then when he got clipped and
dropped I was like, oh you know,
I thought it was going to get caught
with the left talk cause I'm saying cause
we were um,
there was the UFC Adelai card on at the
same time and we were at the Fox studios
and when the Fox did outside
the UFC deal with Fox is up,
they switched to Pacific CCO,
PCB Pacific coast boxing of which
Deontay wilder. He's one of their guys.
So in the room where we were watching,
watching the Adelaide card,
they've got the fucking day autopilot.
If Tyson fury fight on,
now I've got to talk about the Adelaide
card in detail and break it down and
this and that.
But this is one of the
greatest heavyweight boxing
advise you've ever seen in
your life going on and
that screen over there.
So I'm like this watch and the doing
this tell us. It was crazy. It was crazy.
Anyway, but as I was
watching it, obviously the,
I was looking for that big right
hand and fury was doing a very,
very good job of rolling away from it.
Just a boat in that sharp. And I said,
if he follows that with a left hook,
he's going to catch him.
And eventually that's what happened.
I was exactly what it was.
And as he was going down,
which is even more spectrum,
I think he clipped him with the first one.
I clipped him with the right hand and
caught him with a left hook or as he was
going down.
And the fact that he
got up after he was flat on his back,
his arms are down.
I think six out of 10 referees would
have stopped that fight right there.
They would have waved it off.
Oh, for sure. Yeah, no, he looked
for a moment. He looked dead. Yeah,
he looked out. Yeah. So part of me
didn't look dead. He looked at you,
looked knocked out,
it looked unconscious for a few seconds,
and then the lights came back on.
And I know he came.
It's interesting when I did,
when a judge or referee rather,
it has a decision to make, whether
or not they decided to stop a fight.
And it's one of the more frustrating
things ever when the referee stops a fight
prematurely.
It's rough.
But then when you look at a fight like
the Donna Stevenson fight this weekend,
and I don't remember how to pronounce the
Russian Gentleman's name, it's with it.
Geez. Yeah. He, the guy who
knocked out, I didn't see this,
but they're a is in hospital
and in critical condition
might now, correct. Yes.
Yes.
And he's gone undergone brain surgery.
He's got a,
apparently he's got bleeding on the
brain. And it was, uh, it was, uh,
it was a good knockout, but it wasn't
particularly, it wasn't insanely. Yeah.
Yeah. So when you look to that, you didn't
think this guy's going to have issues.
Yeah.
See he sat up,
he got up there like he looks like
he's okay and it looked like, you know,
that's the problem with boxing, you
know, um, I think what, what is it,
12 to 15 deaths per year in boxing
around the world? It's a very,
very sad stat, I guess. You know, I mean,
you involved with the UFC, you know,
all the, the pro ever May, um,
dialogue that's put out there.
You know what?
Boxing is more dangerous because he's
only punches to the head and they can take
more blogs. But that is the thing and get
it is true blow. It is, it is true. Yeah.
For sure. The slightly bigger gloves,
you take more shots, which has,
you know what, that's the
argument get effect on the brain.
American football versus rugby as well.
Rugby's a better, safer sport. Yeah.
Which is crazy because there's no pads,
no helmets, no nothing. Right. But yeah,
but it's a better state of my
favorite ones. Have a dad in rugby.
It's not something that I hear about. It's
not a narrative. I'm sure if someone's,
probably not for sure exactly what sport,
but I don't think it's a thing. No,
but unfortunately, I mean you
see, I mean the poor guys,
you see kids at high school,
there was one on the news I
think a couple of years ago,
close to where I live down here. And uh,
yeah, heartbreaking. I would never let,
yeah,
my kids play football. My kids
wanted to find, I'd say, look,
you're going to learn how
to fight correctly, but if
you want to play football,
get the fuck.
Got It. Yeah. It's just too many
guys running at you. Full clip,
clash and helmet to helmet. Well that's
the thing because the young kids,
the young kids and you know,
I remember when I was that age,
you think you're invincible.
So part of me you where you think you're
invincible and certainly then you put
on this giant helmet and you think you
can just charge him with your head.
You know what I mean? And unfortunately
that isn't the case. We've
gone over some of the most
recent statistics that
they've released on CTE would
football players and they're talking
about from pop Warner to high school to
college to professional the
number like across the board,
the number that exhibits CT symptoms
is staggering. Right. It's, you can only
imagine the vast majority I'm sure it is.
It's crazy to fucking nutty sport.
Rugby's better.
It's a better sport and it's a better
sport. Why? In terms of, it's a bit,
it's up to me.
I
playbook bay. I used to love rugby. I was,
I was a pretty good rugby player
when I was younger. But uh,
it seems surprising to hear that
from an American and you know,
I don't watch football
have an America and Joe,
you know who the big American flag
behind you and you got the fucking,
what are those?
What is that?
That's what we'll do at
least know that is a,
an Asian water buffalo from [inaudible].
My next guest is it the will to visa
the Asian Water Buffalo. That's from me.
Good mate. Adam Green Tree. Ah, who shot
that sucker and brought it over for me.
Nice, nice decoration. But that's
an invasive species in Australia.
They shoot them out of helicopters. Oh
really? They have to kill him. There's,
they don't have any,
any other than crocodiles,
but there's no Jeremy till flesh on it.
But if that thing had meat in flesh
and bones, so much brilliant. Got me.
I Shit my pants walking gigantic.
The size of those are horns, man.
And it's a huge animal. Oh, knocking on
the imagine. Yeah, I was. Yeah. Cows.
They're gigantic. Well, they have
cows over there that are wild.
They're called Scrub Bulls.
Right.
But you know how like we see a Rodeo
rider rides a bowl and the bulls like get
the crazy.
Well that's because they've
got testosterone and giant
balls and they're fucking
super aggressive.
You never see a bowl in the wild.
I used to work at slaughter house.
I used to smart 500 cows a day.
The size of those fucking bowls
will scare you to death hammers.
I wasn't looking at the Cox. I know
that. I'm saying that their balls,
they're like, oh yeah,
yeah, no, no. When I was 16,
now that I've come from a
small town and one of the, uh,
the local employers is there,
the slaughterhouse and anyone,
any young loser like myself has done a
stint at the slaughter house when they
need a job,
you know?
And I went in and I was squeegeeing
mopping blood into the drains.
I was like, what the fuck is this? So
I said to the forum and I said, listen,
I could be of more use to you than
this. He said, let me think about it.
So when I've hammer break, I'm a bacon
sandwich. Came back and he's like, Yep,
you're right. You're a good kid.
I'm going to make you an apprentice.
Slaughterman I was like, holy fuck,
that's not what I was looking for.
And talk about shocking.
Oh,
I'd never seen anything like it
in my life. It was insane. Insane.
And I'm offending all the vegans and
animal lovers am an animal lover big time,
you know? But, uh, it,
you've got to make ends meet when you
were a kid living in a small town. Yeah.
Yeah. So how'd you swaddle
them? Well, the, the, the,
the line up single file.
And eventually they come into like a
little cubicle like this and you're
standing above them and as they come
in, you push a button, door drops down,
and they're in this confined
environment like a big rectangle,
like a big cubicle, and you're
raised up and you have this bell.
You touched her head and then to knock
it on the head, that shoots a bolt,
falls down and falls into the wall.
Then you push a button and the
slides up and the cow rolls down.
So you went down the statue
and as you ruining down,
you grab what's called a puffin road.
It's like a eight foot long flexible
piece of plastic and he's in sterilized
liquid. You pull that out as you run
down. Then you put your light neon belly,
you put your knee on the,
uh, the head of the cow,
you feel for the hole you
just made in the hair.
Then you get the end of the piff him Rod.
He push it into the hole,
he feed it all the way in until
it's all the way into this.
About this much at the top
of the headlines Arrive
by eight foot, eight foot,
and you feed it all the way cause he
goes down the spinal column. So you're,
you're, you're killing all that. You
killing all the nerve endings. Wow.
Eyes are popping out of his head to
things fucking kicking like a maniac.
You've got your knee on it.
Then you pull that out,
put it back in the sterilized thing. You
get a chain, put it around the rear foot,
push a button. It's strange. You don't
pull out your knife here to here. It
guts elevator doors like the
shining blood everywhere. Does it.
Next one run back upstairs. Netscout's
goal and if you're not quitting and I go,
mother Fucker, let's
go. Come on. 500 a day.
I was such a person has such a little bit,
I couldn't do it.
I'm going to fuck this. Fuck this. I'm
going to have nightmares when I go home.
I did it for about two weeks and I'm like,
yeah, I'm out. I'm out. See you buddy.
Too. Disturbing way to
disturb him and, and,
and the people that work there a
little disturbed as well, you know,
going imagine you'd get a little twisted
a couple of years in job. I mean,
I think they were fucking with me
cause I was a kid. Right. You know,
because obviously from there
then they get, you know,
the chance odd in half and they
start looking like meat, you know,
they'd go up and they take it back. Yeah.
Ticket by Mike. It's an acquired taste,
you know, and it would
eat it, raw it dead.
They were just doing it to fuck with
me, you know, you know what I mean?
Little 16 year old kid wet
behind the ears. But uh, yeah,
I didn't know that was
stuck of rod through this,
the whole in the brain all the way
through the spot. It's pretty shocking.
You know, I've never even heard of
something like that. Yeah. Pythian Rod,
that's what you call.
Wow.
I wonder if that's standard practice
still today because I never,
I've never seen it. I've seen some
awful Peter slaughterhouse. Yeah, yeah.
But they died quick. It was
weird. Instantly it very,
very quick. Yeah. And you get through
enough in one day, I couldn't do it.
Now there's no way I could do it
now as when you're young, you know,
you morals change as you get older,
your feelings or your values
change couldn't do it would,
if that was the only source of meat,
it was mild sauce, salsa and you meat,
then the mother fuckers, Dane. You know
what I mean? Yeah. But I'm not a a,
I know you're a big hunting
guy. I'm not a bit, well,
I've never been hunted in my life,
but if you're gonna eat it to live and
then then, then good for you. Of course.
You know, it serves a purpose. Yeah. Well,
I became a hundred because of
those videos. Which videos?
So it was Peter videos of
slaughterhouses. Oh really? Yeah.
Now I want to have any part
of that. I know we're well,
exactly. And I know, and I,
I respect that. I do. I'm
not so much into their, well, I detest
it. Trophy hunting and things like that,
you know, I know that's a no, no,
I'm not into it either. I mean,
I really don't understand
the desire to hunt something.
You're not interested in eating
[inaudible] rich businessmen flying out to
Africa and you know,
shooting a majestic base or an
elephant or a lion from a distance.
There's no water in that. There's no honor
in shooting Elian even from close up.
But from desk is hiding in the
bushes and pulling a fucking trigger.
Anything that makes you a
man, even though, you know,
the only way that makes sense to me is
if you're in a part of Africa where lions
are consistently killing your livestock
and you have to protect your livestock,
which is yet Colorado.
There's a big issue with mountain lions
and Sean and a lot of it, Wyoming,
there's a lot of places that have hunting
seasons on mountain lions. Absolutely.
Yeah. I wouldn't say there's a hard and
fast rules for everything in different
environments, different situations than
you need, you know, a different approach,
you know?
Well,
you know that Cecil the lion thing and
that whole story that went down and you
know what happened? I, uh, I'm pretty, if
you remind me, I think I know about it.
I remember hearing something about it.
A famous majestic lion that was in this
park and the lion left the park and went
into this area where it's
legal for them to hunt.
And a hunter who was a dentist
from America shot this lion,
right?
And everyone became very mad at this
guy because the line had a collar on it,
which meant that there was a
line that they were tracking.
Because the thing is that they can't see
the collar when they're trying to shoot
it.
They have this giant Maine,
there's no way you're gonna see this
dentist from somewhere in America.
So he's a fucking asshole
in my territory where I'm allowed
to shoot. All right. Gray area,
I guess.
But the fact that you're flying out to
fucking Africa to shoot majestic base for
me,
that that's a weak excuse.
It is it from a guy that you just
fucking kill five of cows a deck.
Here's where it's fucked up for a week.
And I was an apprentice.
I didn't really do it very often when
the very nice flash hit in all these
people were furious at that guy and
then no one wanted to go over there and
hotlines. So because no one wanted
to go over there and hunt lions,
the lion population exploded when
the lion population exploded.
The undulate population or the,
you know,
antelope and all those and
yet have dropped radically.
She saw the wildlife biologists made an
assessment that they had to kill some
lions so they killed,
I think they wound up killing 200
lions and just dumping their bodies.
Whereas for the money would
have gone for those 200 lines,
they would have gotten $50,000 for
each line of a hunter had taken them.
And then what they've done,
they take that money,
they pour it back into conservation. It's
a very messy business. Sure, absolutely.
You know, and then there you go. There
is the, the the argument for it. Yeah,
but it's a tricky argument to eight.
It is a tricky argument because I don't
have the answers and I'm not educated
enough to really sit here and debate or
really cast any kind of opinion on any
one really. I just shooting an animal
from a distance. I'm not a fan of.
That's about it from a distance.
You kind of have to, yeah, no,
for sure. I can force you to elk up
close. That's a real problem. Oh yeah. No,
actually you gonna shoot first and I'm
not talking about you going out and, uh,
I've, I've seen your videos on your
barbecue. It looks fucking delicious.
You should try it. I'm sure it's
great. I'm sure it's awesome.
I have no issue with that. I have you. So
please. I would love to eat it. You Go.
Holy Shit. I'm sure I would. Doesn't taste
like anything else, man. I love meat.
I'm a carnivore for sure. Um, but yeah,
yeah, no, you're right. Look,
it's the argument for it.
You can make the same argument for people.
Hey, we'll keep these people healthy.
We just kill a couple
of, well, there you go.
Exactly how you have these really
rich people come over from Germany.
They spend $100,000 no
kill a few poor people,
and that the rest of the poor people,
they're going to get all this money
and there'll be more houses for them.
All right now there, visit enough
accommodation for everybody to live in.
Let's just slow,
let's just call,
which is 2000 let them loose in the hills
and we'll chase him with bows and just
kill a few of these people. It's tricky,
you know, it's not good. It's not.
It's the kill some of the rapists
and murderers coming over the border,
job solved,
and then the other,
the other problem is even
the animals that make sense.
I don't think there's rapists
and murderers coming off
the bottom was probably,
let's be honest, most of them were
just poor folks and want a better, oh,
for sure. Yeah, no shame on that.
You're an immigrant. My family, I mean,
we're all proud product of
immigrants and so 100 but yeah,
of course you native American,
he's probably shut the
fuck up 100% there you go.
Yeah. No, that's totally fair. Yeah, no,
I know. That's the funny thing. I'm like,
really fucking show me a third
generation American in this country.
Did the hard to come across.
They are,
you know everybody I meet out here claims
to be English when I made them out.
Have my mom, my fucking Auntie's English
or Irish or they'll claim to be out.
You guys love to claim an Irish descent.
Really? Oh yeah. Is this recent?
This is because of Conor McGregor.
You guys fucking love. Declare my,
my mom's Irish. My mom
has an Irish accent. Okay.
She fucking talks like desk maker.
She's Avish as the car.
I've never once claimed to be Irish. There
you go. I use what I say to everybody.
They're like, oh yeah, I'm
Swiss. I'm Italian. I'm this.
Does anybody in your immediate
family talk with an Italian accent?
Now we'll shut the fuck up because
you're American. Okay. And that's okay.
That's okay. Be Proud of that.
Yeah, you're not English.
Just cause you great. Great,
great, great grandmother grew up in
Ipswich or Gloucester or somewhere.
Does it make you, you
English love? So your kids,
your kids' kids will be
American. Oh yeah. Well, yeah,
we got green cards recently, so
yeah. Oh yeah. They will be. Yeah.
How does that work?
You have to mind your p's and q's.
If you get in trouble over
here, they ship you back. Um,
I guess that's tricky, right? That's
one good thing about what I'm, okay.
You know, 20 years ago it would have been
an issue, but these days I'm a fireman.
I'm a gentleman and I'm going to find
gentleman, Jack, come on. Businessman,
a commentator.
God cast.
You're doing movies the place. Yeah. I
forget what. They don't have to worry.
We're not, we're not hanging out in
bars getting knocked out by Gypsies.
They were the old days. You aren't
getting into the movie business, right?
You've been doing a few movies.
Why aren't you doing a movie during the
time you were doing the Rockhold fight?
That's right. Yeah. I was
filming triple X. Yeah. Yeah.
I've been out there for about three months
and then I was flying home and I was
looking for some walkie talkies
for my seven year old. Uh,
I don't know why I thought
that'd be a good idea.
It turns out getting hold of walkie
talkies isn't very easy these days.
I've went on a fucking wild goose chase
trying to get these fucking walkie
talkies that didn't even get played
with. He was like, yeah, cool.
I've got a phone dad. I like, yeah,
I should've thought of that. But um,
and as I'm looking for them,
I check Twitter,
I've got a coffee and a see Chris
Weidman and pulled out. So yeah,
it takes Dane and I said, listen, if this
is true, you know, you know where I am.
And he was like, oh great, we love that,
you know, blah blah blah blah blah.
But Jack Arrays our first option.
So I thought for a minute there,
I thought I was getting a
title shot and I thought,
there's no way Jackie is
going to turn it down.
So I went to my buddy's Jason's house
and watched the basketball game and I had
a few drinks and you know, it didn't
party as such. I was on set the next day,
but had a few drinks. Now, if I knew I was
fighting for a world belt in two weeks,
you know,
I would have been on a strict diet,
not overindulging but I
definitely over indulged.
And then the next day and walking
into the gym, just have, you know,
just a little light workout and my phone
starts exploding lighting up like a
Christmas tree and like what the hell?
And then our aerial Hawaiian, he calls me,
is that Mike Dana just announced a sports
center that you're fighting for the
belt.
What the fuck?
I was the first day I heard about it. I
look fucking Dana, we all, God bless him.
So, um, that whole shit. So I'm panicking
like crazy. How much did you work?
So that's the first thing I did. I ran
into the changing of, got on the scale.
I was like two 15, two 16 cause
that rough. Yeah, for sure. Yeah,
I like to do like a week
before I like to be 200 pounds.
So this is two weeks before and um,
I'm 215 so my shit screwed
the weights and need to run.
So I just run out at the gym,
throw my backpack on my shoulders and
just of sprinting through Toronto city
center, like a mad man. Of course
there's traffic lights every 30 seconds.
So I don't want to stop at the
traffic lights cause that's no good.
So I'm just running out,
nearly getting one over by taxis and
jumping over homeless people falling over,
ducking and dive. And it was great
training. And um, and then Dana called,
who's I'm negotiating, you know, the
Fi whilst running through Toronto.
And then, uh, carried on going and then
I end up laying in the middle of nowhere.
I just running and running and running.
And then Jason Parillo gets
on the phone and uh, you know,
all the doubt starts creeping in. I
start thinking, Jesus Christ is salt.
Typical of my career, I've wanted a
towel fight my whole career. You know,
I've been through many ups
and downs and now here I am.
I get the towel fights on two weeks.
Notice I'd be filming a God damn movie.
I've been near a gym,
MMA gym for a while doing anything unless
against somebody that's already beaten
me. So I'm kind of destined to
fail this soft fucking typical.
And then Jason got on the phone and
you know, he talks to round big time.
You know, I said a lot of very positive
things. Jason's an amazing coach.
Absolutely is incredible. It
really is. There's a lot of,
it was a lot of trainers out there.
Uh, there's a lot of pad men. You know,
there's a lot of fakers in mixed martial
arts. Certainly these days. You know,
I mean guys that really have true heritage
in martial arts or any kind of steep
history in combat sports, they're few
and far between. You know, you can train,
any guy can watch a video and
it's a little bit of coordination,
how to hold pads and you see them.
It's all the crazy, isn't it?
These days in pads to get fit, you
know, one, two left talk, Woo. You know,
just cause you can do that
and hold it doesn't make you,
a coach does not make you a coach.
And there's a lot of fakers out there,
but Jason is not one of them.
He speaks from the heart and he knows
what the fuck he's talking about.
And we had a good chat and by the end
of it I was, I was feeling a lot better.
And uh, yeah. So when you were filming
that movie, were you working out at all?
I was doing vanity workouts.
I like to run certainly
when I'm in a city.
So I was running probably three or
four days a week of 4.2 mile run. Yeah.
Yes. So as I was running and I was lifting
weights a few times a week, you know,
biceps and shoulders, you know what
I mean? Yeah. The chest, press luck,
lots of jazz press, you know
what I mean? Uh, and then, um,
GSPs coach Jorge Blanco. Do you know
Jorge? No, I don't. It's very, very,
very good trainer. I'm Rashad Evans
put me onto him whilst I was up there.
I went to see him like two or three
times, you know, uh, but no, not,
not training as such, but uh, yeah,
all worked out. But it exercise.
But sometimes that's good anyway.
Right?
So it gives your body a chance to recover.
Well,
that's what I said afterwards because I
went into that fight feeling so strong,
feeling so good.
I'm like,
cause I consistently have a trend every
single fight in my career apart from
that one. Uh, and I said, oh, I'll
learn from this. I'll learn from this.
And you don't, and it's like
Jason Parillo always says, um,
it takes confidence to take a day
off to rest the body, you know?
And now of course there's a fine line
between having the confidence to take a
day off and being a lazy bastard and said,
I'm going to sit on the couch today.
You know? But if you could,
if you know, listen, I'm good.
I'm going to take a day or two
off cause I need it, you know?
So that was one of the
mistakes I made with my career.
I always trained too much in Jason said,
you know,
I used to mind fuck myself because
it meant so much to me. You know,
my fight career meant so much to me.
I used to overcomplicate it over analyze,
you overwork it, stress myself out
with it, you know, and uh, that,
that was hindering my performances.
You know, I never once fought to the,
to my ability of, I performed
in the gym, never once. Uh,
I remember one day I pulled up outside
Ruca and Jason was waiting for me outside
and I pulled up and he says, Mike, come
in and cut me. Have a quick chat. I said,
yeah, what's up? He said, listen buddy,
you go guys in there. Okay. He said,
but you're a fucking world champion.
Can you go in there and spar these
guys and act like a world champion?
They're here. You're up there,
act like it. Don't go in,
lose your fucking tempest.
Spazz out. Stress out at like
a dig. Say things you regret.
You know when the spine is not quite
necessarily going your way, you have,
you know, you get a little
pissed off or whatever, you know,
say Jiu Jitsu coaches catching you and
tapping you out a little bit and you
start getting a little frustrated.
He said, can you just, you know,
how can we have none of that place and
great advice. Just like when I, uh,
I was fighting for the belt when
I flew home from doing that movie,
I went straight to the gym when I
landed. And, uh, Jason said to me,
cause I was always stressed, you
know, and he said, listen, um,
we don't know if you're going to win this
fight, Mac. You know, fingers crossed,
I believe in you.
I believe you're gonna win this fight,
but we don't know if you're
going to win this fight.
So this might be the only time you're
ever going to fight for a world title.
Right. I said, well, yeah, but he said,
well, let's enjoy the process. You know,
let's go through this with a smile on
your face. He said, this is huge. He said,
you're in a position that
everyone would kill to be in.
You're fighting for the championship,
you're find for the belt.
You've wanted this whole, this your
whole life, enjoy this. You know,
and it was such amazing advice cause
I was like, yeah, you're right.
And I went through the whole thing
and the big smile on my face,
new clip. Rockhold I
remember thinking, Holy Shit,
when I see rock holds legs buckle and I
see him stagger backwards. I was like,
Holy Shit.
He got him.
And then when he stumbling as the cage
and you bashed him and stopped him,
I'm going to help but laugh because
you know it does bring a smile to her.
Almost like I couldn't believe it. It was
like a, like a movie. It was like, it was,
it was one of those things because you
were a big underdog coming third fight.
Everybody know you took
it on short notice.
Everybody knew that you were working on
a movie and so for you to land that when
you landed that left hand,
you missed it once before too.
And I remember thinking like, man,
that is fucking close. That's close.
Like you saw this opening
for that left hand and you,
you clipped him over the top of the
shoulder. It didn't see it. Common Bang.
You drop that left hand on his chin and
you see like his eyes rolled back and
his legs give out
black man. Well that was the whole
plan, the left Hook, you know,
Jason and seeing that it was open for
that and I'd seen it was open for that and
he was even doing this exercise on
these bands are like a resistance bands,
whatever it was doing this
and his chin was open,
his right hand was down at the end of it.
And Jason said he's,
he's Julian needs moves
here and he's finishing here
that left hook all day long.
And um,
you know,
he's coming forward and we're exchanging
punches and nothing really significant
as Landon. And I just ran up to the
battery, just whipped the left talk.
And you know, as a, when you,
when you land a good shot, you,
cause you get the feedback on your fist,
there's nothing like it.
You know what I mean? When,
when you, when you feel that,
that solid connection and the knuckles
got through the glove, you know,
and you feel it, you're like,
oh, that was a good one.
And then he falls down on that holy shit
all around and then he gets back up on
that, fuck you bomb
back down. And then, uh,
he went down and obviously he's got
very good Jujitsu and he was kind of sat
back against the fence and I thought,
I've got to be careful not to go in his
guard, but uh, yeah, I got the finish.
Felt the best feeling I've ever felt in
my life was big John Mccarthy's gigantic
forearm, nearly pulling my head off my
shoulders as he wrestled me off him.
But he knew it was over because
I knew it was over. It was great.
What did that feel like
when you knew you did it?
One of the best feelings in the world?
One of the best, because you know,
for me, you know, the
amount of fights I've had,
this unbelievable professionally
and unprofessionally, you know,
and when I was a kid,
that's all I was, you know,
that that was my only identity has been
a fire. You know, I'm just being that,
that guy, you know, unfortunately rightly
or wrongly works wrongly, wrongly,
you know, of course it is.
You know, I was, I was a
fucking idiot when I was a kid.
I was fighting so much, but
that's what I clung to, you know,
I was a fire and that was the only thing
that I could draw pride from, you know,
and, uh, be becoming the world champion,
knowing that everybody wrote me off
knowing that everyone talk shit about me,
you know, uh, other fighters
just, just, you know,
it was everywhere. [inaudible] I heard
what people always said about me.
Do you know what I mean? So to, to win
lie that in style and the first one. Yeah.
Yeah. It felt amazing. It is
right there. Oh yeah, yeah.
[inaudible] was very upset.
Yeah, he was. Yeah. You know,
you talked a lot of shit too and you, and
after you beat him, well, well, hold on.
I know my wife was behind me there and
she deserves a shout out because if it
wasn't for her, none of this
would've happened. But, uh,
with Rockhold with what happened
after the fight. So I, okay,
there's a few things that I regret that
have heard after the fact. First of all,
I jumped on the fence and I'm just all
worked up Husky that fuck you, whatever.
No big deal. I'm not, I'm not
too concerned about that one. Um,
and then as I'm doing my lap of
victory dance, if you will, um, I,
I do a lap of the octagon
and I crossed paths with,
with Luke part of me and
I'm like, Hey, you know,
you say whatever you say,
unlucky bird, you know, a good
fire, whatever. Bubba, Bubba,
bubba.
I said that.
And I carried on having my mom and I
was just out of my mind on Adrenalin and
just having a great time.
And then I found myself,
I'd done an entire lap of the octagon
again and I was passing him again.
So I just thought I'd extended my curtsy
one more time. I'm like, yeah, you know,
and I put my hand out and he
said, oh, really? Shook your
hand. I'm like, oh, really?
You're still going to be a decade. Is
that yet? I already shook your hand.
So then I was like, okay,
well now the gloves are off.
I said, don't worry about it.
You're in an octagon. You've
just been knocked out. It's okay.
You'll figure it out in a minute. Don't
worry about it. You'll come to buy,
you'll be good.
So I kind of look like an asshole
because people didn't see that he would,
it was used to shake my hand the
second time. You know, I was like,
well go fuck yourself then.
And then when you gave me the microphone,
when you gave him the microphone, I said
the most crude comments ever I'm at,
I've been fighting ever since. I care
about it. My mother, I'm not whoa.
That's not an image that I want to
portray to the world when the world belt,
you know, what I meant was ever since
I've been born. Right. You know, but in,
in the moment,
the word's escaped me a little bit and
then I painted a rather disturbing image
of my mother giving birth
to me. But, uh, but yeah,
I didn't choose my words too
carefully though, but, uh,
yeah, no, it was great man.
Be held accountable for
that. I mean, that's it.
There's no one that's ever gonna be able
to understand that other than someone
who wins the title. Yeah. No one's
going to know what that felt like. Oh,
it's impossible.
18 it was incredible. It really
was. It really was. Yeah.
I can only imagine it was
good while it was good.
Just happy that for you. Uh, you know,
having a chance to see all your fights
and see your career go for as long as it
went that you did go out
with a title that is,
yeah, for sure. Yeah. You
know, I mean, as I say a,
that was for me, I'm not sure.
Well, I wouldn't have retired.
I wouldn't have retired. Yeah,
yeah. No, no, because, because I,
I know I could still do it. I can still
find now, you know, I can still, but,
but the time was right.
You know,
and then I started having issues with
my good eye as well after the gas Dillon
fight. So I'm like, this isn't worth it
now because you, you had oil in
one of your eyes. Yeah. Yeah.
Can you explain how that was going on?
Yeah. So when I detached my retina, um,
they did what's called a
[inaudible]. Uh, if you,
if you've watched their surgery,
it's absolutely disgusting.
But, uh, one of the things that
they do, the gas inside your eye,
and I think if I'm getting this wrong,
I apologize to all doctors,
but the kind of kind of helps
hold the retina in place. Um,
but you can't fly with that.
And I was filming a movie in England
a few weeks later. I said, and I said,
you can't do the US and I'm filming
a movie. And they went, okay,
there's another way we can do it.
It's a little more unconventional.
We can put oil inside there, but then
with that you can fly. So I'm like, okay,
cool. Do that. So, uh, they did that. Uh,
yeah. You know, it's,
yeah.
Nah. And then we detoxed and then I've got
glaucoma. I just had a lot of bad luck.
I did whatever can go wrong with
an I trust me. I went through it.
But it looks different now. Yeah,
it does. Yeah, it does. Yeah.
But it looks better than it looked
before was great. What did you do?
It looks great. Don't worry about it. Job.
Oh, you want to talk? No, no, you're good.
You got it. It's okay. It's a,
it's a corrective lens. Oh, okay.
It's a corrective lenses.
A prosthetic.
So can you see,
I see, I see. Um, a tiny,
tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny,
tiny bit. Oh, really? Yeah. So I don't,
I don't really see out of it and
divisions very blurred. I'm going to,
I was able to pass the test to pass,
to be able to clear by commission to buy,
you got to have 2100 vision,
which I was able to scrape by with
the skin of my teeth. Wow. You know,
so I'm a doctor was always amazed that
I could still see to that amount if I,
if I squinted in the right direction
and a Turd here and the light was just
right, I could just about
make out 2100. Wow. So, uh,
but what happens is then that then,
cause you see in two different images
distorted him and you see your brain
councils the distorted one,
you know,
so with the depth
perception remains the same.
No depth perception is a real
issue. Yeah. Yeah. You know, uh,
it was an issue throughout my last few
fights. For me, the main thing, I mean,
as I say, you know, uh,
I was cleared medically by the doctors
and you know, the UFC were very,
very on top of all of
that. The UFC, you know,
send me to a number of different doctors
and whatnot. And as I say, uh, uh,
pass the test just, but it was, and
every time I did the doctors were like,
we don't recommend that you fight.
You know, you of course, 2100 vision,
it's still clinically blind.
Uh, yeah. Yeah, yeah. So, um,
but, but yeah, yeah, there you
go. That's fucking crazy. Yeah.
But it never slowed me down. It didn't
slow it down. That's what's crazy.
Looking back now,
lay fi,
not that I sit there at night and
get drunk and watch my old fights.
I've never done that once.
But if I ever do see some old fights back,
which occasion just happens by
chance, you know, afterwards,
I'm always calling for a shot at the
belt or whatever. I said to my wife,
fuck with this guy. Thank you. Get out
of it. He's out of his mind, you know,
absolutely out of his mind.
But at that time,
it quitting and trying to not be come
the champion did not even occur to me for
a split second. Giving up never
even occurred to me for a heartbeat.
Why is that? Is this how you've always
been? This is something I still felt.
I still felt that I could, I could
win it. Simple as that, you know? Uh,
but a lot of guys,
if they lost most of the use of one of
their eyes would have been done. Yeah,
for sure. No, no chance. It's not
worth it. Yeah. No, I know. Um,
and
okay,
probably the smart thing to do would it,
what would have been one of those guys,
but for me, you know, I, I, it
meant a lot to me. I want it.
I wanted to become the champion.
I knew I could become the champion
contrary to popular belief.
And um, this is me. They, they,
it was my identity. And until I won that
belt, I wasn't happy. Now when I want it,
my wife said she wanted me to be. So
when I fought Luke in, in La, she said,
if you win, I want you
to retire. I said, Bev,
if I lose then I'll retire. Okay. Cause
Fair enough. I got my towel sharp.
You know, it didn't go on
my way. It is what it is.
I would have had closure on that. I said,
well, if win. Yeah. The fucking mind.
If you think I'm going to retire, you
come on, on the jump into the world.
I got to milk it for a little bit, finally
earn some decent pay days, you know. Uh,
so yeah, but um, it all worked out
or the big fight with GSP. Oh yeah.
That's why that took place because you
had that belt. Yeah. You know, I mean,
I mean, joy joy's beat me fair
and square that night. But, uh,
there was a lot going on going into
that camp that, uh, the final week and,
and again,
I never said anything at the time because
God bless George and he's a great guy
and I respect the hell out of George.
I really do. How can you not, you know,
I mean, I know I talked to all
that shit, lead it into the fire,
but that was just me having a laugh, you
know? I was literally having fun with it.
You know? No ill will towards George
seem like you're enjoying it. Yeah.
Just having fun, just busting
balls. You know what I mean?
I think George is incredible. I think
George is the consummate professional,
easier inspiration to all aspiring martial
artists out there. If there's one man,
you can muddle your career on the way
Twain's the way he looks after his body,
the way cross trains George Saint
Pierre will be that man. You know,
he's an inspiration to
myself, you know, so, uh,
nothing but the greatest of respect.
But people,
as we said at the start of the show,
that doesn't sell.
People don't want to see that.
People don't want to see that,
so I'll play the bad guy. I've been
portrayed as the bad guy my entire career,
you know, by the UFC,
the editing, you know,
I've fallen foul to some creative editing.
I've fallen foul to my own mouth as well
at time. So, you know, come on. You know,
I'm my own worst enemy as well. But um,
the week before the phone, yeah, we,
before the fight, uh, I had the best
training camp and my life, you know, uh,
sounds braggy, but knocking out multiple
sparring partners, not on purpose.
It just felt incredible.
It felt absolutely incredible.
Final sparring session.
We had my protein,
they'd flown in for a photo shoot or
someone else there for a photo shoot.
The Gym's absolutely packed and we got
some guys in their aspiring me and um,
you know, everybody wants to
be the guy, you know, the, the,
the guests to take down or whatever or
get to submission on the guide. That's,
you know,
that's how it is.
That's why I don't like gone to too many
MMA gyms when I was fine because every
time you walk in you have a target on
your back. Anyway, it was the final round.
We did five rounds,
it was the Friday before the fight and
this guy shooting shoot a double leg
ones. We all the way across the
octagon, like his life depended on, it,
depended on it,
picked me up,
slammed me down and his shoulders
went right into my ribs and I felt it
instantly.
Just all the cartilage tor completely.
And I just started swearing and screaming,
fuck fucking, you know, cause I knew,
I knew I went a saw a doctor and Warner
and a yeah, it wasn't good. So I was,
I got treatment everyday and I was having
nice on me and all that type of stuff.
Uh, but uh, it, it wasn't working. So
what we came up with Kevin with his plan,
it was going to inject myself with
lighter came before the fight cause it,
cause it will nomia but the problem
is the area where it was was, uh, you,
you can pass along.
It's where I have to go in.
You could piss a lot of bleed to
death cause internal bleeding is yet.
So I got this doctor,
I was going to add the needle ahead,
the light again and I was going to fucking
go in and sneak into the toilet and
facetime the doctor and he was like,
okay. And anyway, the whole thing,
can we just do it on top of it was, it
was bullshit. I was like, fuck this,
this is the stupidest plan ever.
Bollocks to it.
I'll fire with the sore rib eye
bit of Adrenalin and you're not,
I've got to feel it anyway, which I didn't
under night, you know. But people said,
Oh, you didn't look yourself in there.
You weren't moving too much. Said yeah,
no shit. I couldn't move. But uh, but
as I said, hey all credit to George,
God bless him. He did great. Did you,
there was a sparring partner that you
had sparked with regularly. He'd came.
Ed Dina. I'm a singer. Great Guy.
Just came in from England for the
last couple of weeks. So as dean,
who took you down? Dean very well.
Do you know dean? Yeah, yeah.
Fucking day in the Prager dude. What the
fuck, dude? Yeah, no, he's a great guy.
Deans are so he's great. Yeah, he's
great. You know, it's the way it goes.
You training and a, yeah. What are
you going to do? So many fights went,
that was half El dos Anjos when he's
supposed to fight McGregor, like last,
last sparring kicks and elbows
and breaks his foot. Oh,
so that's why Diaz care men. Ah,
yeah. It has happened to so many guys.
Such a fine line because, because you
feel good, you've trained so hard,
you feel great and you think, ah,
like your coach will say, okay,
let's call it there guys. We're good.
Call there and you're like, I don't know.
I feel good.
Come on,
let's get one good one is because
sometimes I normally train a spar Monday,
Wednesday, Friday, and if the Wednesday
spire goes really well, you know,
let's end it there because you
want to end on a really good spar.
You know what I mean? Because
you, you feel like a world
champion, you feel great.
You know,
I,
you remember how you handled all your
sparring partners and w whatever good
shots you landed and you didn't really
take any damage. That's a great,
that's great momentum to
go into the fight with.
And you don't know if you have another
spy section, it's going to go like that.
You might be tired,
you might be worn down.
Those guys might be on their game that
day. And if you get a Tufts by session,
well then you want to do one more
because you can't go into a fight after
getting your ass kicked in a sparring
session. You know what I mean?
That's not good Karma or
energy to go in there with. Um,
so it's always a weird one to find.
It's fine balancing gags. But uh, yeah,
there you go. Do you, uh, when
you look back on your career,
would you have done anything differently
in terms of what the way you prepare it?
MMM,
yeah, for sure. For sure. A lot of
things. Yeah. Yeah. You know, I mean
time machine. Yeah. And you'd shoot again.
I do way more things, which
is all different. Well one,
I wouldn't balloon up in between fights,
discipline between fights, you know,
I didn't exercise enough of in between
fights. Yeah. A little too much.
You know, these days I look after my
body way more now than when I was fine.
It's so fucking hypocritical.
You know, it's so silly now. Um,
well cause now I don't have the luxury
of going through a fight camp to get in
shape. You know what I mean? So now I've
got to stay in shape. Simple as that.
Whereas in the past I'm like,
yeah, whatever. I'll have a pizza,
I'll have a few beers I have
for dessert, I'll do, I'll,
I'll eat whatever I want and then when
I'm in training camp, switch it on.
But it's not good for the body. So that
would be one. Um, yeah, many things.
Many things,
you know,
I don't really want to throw
anyone under the bus or whatever,
but yes, training was, did this things
I would have changed, you know, there,
there was a group of people that I was
involved with in England for a while.
Definitely when a wouldn't have wasted
my time with us. Fucking assholes.
Did you get clear of all that legally
now? Not yet. Still going on this Friday.
There's another hearing in the
courts. Yeah. She's lots of lies.
Lots of this has been going on for eight
years. He has something like that. Yes.
It's 2011.
So I remember you telling me about this
when we were in England together. Yeah.
That was a long time ago, man. It
was a very long time ago. Yeah.
What are you going to do that
there's a lot of scumbags out there.
People that want to take your money.
So it's hard for young fighters too
when they get contractually obligated to
someone that doesn't suit
them later in their career.
But then they started becoming successful
and they're still contractually
obligated to those three for sure. That
it's a very common issue with fighters.
Yeah.
Well for me, I was contractually
obligated, uh, I kept my mouth shut. I,
I did my five years and move down.
But uh, they saw it a different way.
So they came out with from
totally fabricated nonsense
about camp bill is going
back to 2006 they just
created invoices and
just just totally fabricated an
entire case. Not a single email,
not a single signature, nothing. It's
laughable that even got this far.
But if you've got brass balls on you and
you're willing to stick to a story and
talk a lot of shit and lie you,
you can,
you can go a long way it seems,
but I don't want to talk about that too,
cause they're a pub in and
getting fucking suit again.
You thought about training fighters.
I would love to.
Yeah.
I really would love to because I feel
this was one of my issues as I was a
coach. So part of me as a, as a
fighter because believe it or not,
you know, I mean I retired
at 39 years old. Um,
and at the time it had the most
fights in the UFC, you know, whatever,
believe it or not,
I know a thing or two about how to
prepare for a mixed martial arts fight,
you know? So that was one of my
conflict things always with my coachees.
I not that I didn't respect them,
but I,
I would always kind of feel maybe I should
be doing this or she'll be doing that
and, and, and that's what I would do a
lot of the time. I was like Cadillac,
the head coach. I mean, Jason
Parillo was probably the head coach,
but I would like be the one that did
the program and need to work on this.
I'll see that guy on that day, you
know? Um, so yeah, I would love to.
I would love to. Right now I've
got a lot of things going on and,
and life is good, so I don't really
have the time to dedicate myself to it.
Right. And actually I'm kind of enjoying
just, well, I'm still working for the UFC,
doing the, you know,
the Fi coverage stuff.
But it's enjoyable to be
doing something different.
You'd have to being submerged in it,
totally submerged for so long,
it's refreshing to be doing something
else, you know? So, uh, but, but,
but one day I would love to for sure.
Well you're seeing it with fighters.
Um,
there's some of them that are making
those transitions into training and who
better to know what it's like to prepare
for a fight and someone like yourself
who had so many fights in the UFC.
I mean,
if it's almost like that knowledge and
experiences almost wasted or at least
goes the, the experience of how to
prepare kind of goes away if you,
if you don't pass it off,
he,
because otherwise someone has
to go through all this stuff.
Yeah, absolutely. Joe. Um, and the, and
that's partly why I do want to do that.
When the time comes,
as I say it,
would it be fair to anybody right now
because I haven't got the time to commit
right now. I'm working on some things
and hopefully they all come off and, uh,
I've got some free time and I can sit on
my ass. You know, everyone's always like,
oh, congrats on the retirement.
I'm like, fucking retirement.
I'm working harder than ever these days.
You know,
maybe I need to come out of retirement
to get some free time back, you know. Uh,
but, um, when the time comes,
I would love to do that.
That is the best case scenario though,
your situation because you,
you've retired into a
very profitable career,
whereas there's a lot of fighters
they're lost when it's over.
They don't know what to do.
Always scared me. Yeah.
Always scared. Good for you,
good for you for thinking like that.
Terrified me right from day one.
So I left school at 16 me and no
education, like a fucking idiot.
That's one of my big regrets in
life. Small town boy, you know,
northwest of England. Not a lot going
on there. Beautiful little town,
but you know, tiny little town, uh,
not a lot of opportunity and
just fell into a Rut, you know,
working minimum wage in factories,
you know,
from seven in the morning
until six o'clock at night,
just doing mundane medial shit in on.
And I hated it. I hated it. I really did.
And that's why I became
a fiery ultimately.
And it was a very well planned
decision, you know, the whole,
the whole story to me coming to do
this was a, it didn't happen overnight.
You know, there was a steps to it.
What was your first discipline?
I started doing Japanese Jujitsu when I
was eight years old and I was obsessed
with it. So that's how you knew how
to clear the sword. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was obsessed with Japanese
Jujitsu. Reallocate. It's
a great, it's great. Yeah,
I was doing, she, we didn't
know it was Emma back then,
but we were fighting in MMA.
We called it knocked down sport Buddha.
If you, if you Google
it, you can bring it up.
You can pick up some of my FYS knockdown
sport Butoh yeah. Which is MMA,
bare knuckle. Uh, and we have like
these international tournaments against,
you know, men. I was about 15,
something like that at the time.
But uh, yeah, so we do tons of that stuff.
When I was younger, you know, I was,
as I say,
obsessed with martial arts in pretty
much one every single tournament I ever
went in. And then on top of that, and I
was a little shit out and about as well.
So I was having plenty of fight
experience. And then as I said,
just dead end job after dead
end job after dead end job.
And I got to a phase in my life and
met my wife Rebecca and we had kids.
I was like, it's this is this or
that. Life is going to be, you know,
and then my boss at work at the
time, Mick, he said to me, my,
you're pretty intelligent guys.
This is what you want to do for the rest
of your life. And I'm like, fuck no.
He's like, what? Oh, here we go.
Here's one of them. This is wild. Yeah.
May Fight Club Shit. I mean, even
the seedy dark looking background,
the weird lighting.
This is like a scene in the movie.
He walked through fire and you walked
through fire to get here. Oh Jesus.
You do actual fire. Oh, it's like smoking.
There's another one actually
did, which is true to my, uh,
puts good headed on this.
This is why all the way you guys
are dressed and everything. Yeah.
I to this day think that fight should
be held in this sort of a scenario where
there's a large open open air
place like a basketball court.
I just feel like the cage is such a
factor in fight. No, it really is.
It really is. And it allows,
I mean you can use the,
there's one more on there if you can
find it Jamie, which is pretty funny.
The joke had a good laugh and so will
everybody else cause I guess the early
Michael Bisping was on display, we
Bauer eg over and I kick him in the face
right off the bat. But you know the
referee at Ted fight. Um, yeah, the cage.
You can use it as a, uh, you know,
it's, it's, it's another weapon.
You can stall on it. You can lean on it,
you use it to stand up. It's a factor.
It's a huge factor in,
in the UFC.
And it's hard to see sometimes if you're
in the crowd and you've got to post
there as a brand, you wind up looking at
the screens. Yeah, no, absolutely you do.
I was having a me Lewis on
one of our episodes recently.
He was saying, you know,
usually when I probably wrote the
power of that. Hold on a minute.
Where did you ever been front row at
the fight for one cause he was saying I
prefer the first wiser.
I'm like okay well that's what everyone
says that their car get front row
tickets. Okay. You all said, oh I'd
rather be on the first advisor. You know,
cause you ever got to get a sore neck
looking up. I said, well guess what?
When you from rob it's fucking cool.
Okay. You can hear the punches,
you can see the blood and the sweat
from the first riser was good.
I'd be doing commentary for
the first prize. It was great.
That's where all the celebrity,
why was this? Look at this by
Oh Jesus Christ. What? That was
fine in my opinion. He said, fine,
look, I wasn't wearing, he's
wearing wrestling shoes. Yeah,
the old head scissors classic.
There is the uh,
there a a video on flow
grappling from a recent,
a Jujitsu tournament where a guy got
a guy in the is to put him to sleep,
right? Yeah. Right from his guard. Yeah.
Well I wouldn't a couple of that
shitty grappling tournaments.
Well the heads is Yay.
If you can squeeze hard enough,
it wasn't against the
best competition though.
The guy might've been 55 or something.
The deal legit though,
if you get the knees on the right part
of the neck and squeeze like a bitch,
yeah, it hurts. And
especially if you practice it,
I feel like the head scissors or something
like look and think about when you,
when you're synching a
Doris, right? Or when you,
when you go under for
a Doris and you clamp,
we'll hold your hands and you pinch down.
Some guys are expert at absolutely
six squeeze, clamp down.
If you just constantly
drilled out all the time,
you could fuck people up with that. Just
get better at it. Just get better at it.
Like you could,
you could,
I don't want to be the guy going for a
headset is in the UFC and it was that
with his British wrestling.
He let him do that.
It's like the women go over
their head and I've, you know,
in women's Ndna you try
a head and arm as a man,
they're going to take you back
to choke you out. Simple as that.
But yet we'll run the run the
main Liz Carmouche she was Ronda,
his thing was always get that
headlock and then hip toss,
get a girl to the ground and then
you know, get her in a normal,
how does that work on women but not men?
Next heads and necks are even smaller
so they can show stand out of it easier.
You know what I mean?
Really works.
I think what we saw on the Ronda
Rousey fight with Liz Carmouche,
Liz Carmouche took her back and
almost choked her out. Yeah.
And if Liz was the lids of today,
she probably would have choked her
out showing how she just wasn't quite
experienced enough at the time.
I think the reason why you're seeing it
more in women's MMA is because although
the level is very high
with like Valentina's shift
Chenko and you own a unit j
check and Cyborg,
the level the champions is very high.
There's still the lower levels absolutely
near you could watch a guy on an
undercard that's fighting on fight pass
who's a fucking worldclass demon in the
UFC. A man, the women
you're still, there's,
there's way less of them and
the competition is strong. Yeah.
I mean they haven't been doing it as
long but I tell them pool isn't as big.
You know,
women aren't as interested in it.
I was just about to say the percentage
of men interested in pursuing martial
arts and mixed martial arts as opposed
to the percentage of women way lower.
I don't know what the
percentage is of metal.
If we said it's 50 just for
the sake of the argument. Yeah,
women it's going to be 5% if that,
if that it's 5% probably men.
If my wife said, Michael,
I'm going to start training cause I
want to be an MMA or fire. I said,
pack your bags, get out. I'd say,
shut the hell up. Made me a sandwich.
What are you talking about? Come on,
you're going to be an MMA fighter. I
was the mother of your children
get head kicked and just crazy.
So my Thai boxing coach, actually you
mentioned Vinny shoreman at the start.
I used to be in business with Vinnie does
Maurice. Very, very good friend of mine.
He was my Thai boxing coach.
Back to Vinny shoreman. Shout
out to dad's Maurice. And um,
he's uh, his girlfriend, he was calling
him and he's, he's getting, you know,
the mother of his children. She was a Thai
boxer, Cassie and Cassie, no disrespect,
you know,
but to be cornering your loved one that
you were in a relationship and she got
knocked out cold and a Thai boxing fan. I
was like, wow. Does, how do you do that?
And the mental strength to understand
that this is a different relationship.
That she's the student and the teacher
and this is just the way it is. I mean,
that takes a lot. I don't think I
could do that. It's incredible. Well,
it takes a different kind of woman
to want to do that right there.
That kind of woman you go.
I mean,
the worst thing I think you could ever
do is take a woman who wants to fight and
tell him no. Yeah, sure. Yeah.
Cause you're going to find a way,
like if you're dating, don't go.
Good luck with that. Good luck.
Good luck with that one. You're going
to get spinning, kick to the midsection.
Shouldn't bottles. Okay. She's a
fucking monster, isn't she? She's great.
She's awesome. Quickest spinning back
kicks I've ever seen. There's no fair.
She's men.
And,
and I say this with a great
set of respective to women's
mixed martial arts and
I respect everybody that applies themself
and he's willing to get off the couch
and make something of their lives. So, you
know, I'm not being overly judgemental,
but there isn't too many that I
really get excited for and that really
thoroughly enjoy watching. You
know, because as we just said,
the level of skill isn't quite
there yet. You know, as I say,
it's not nothing to do with genders.
Right.
Why do I want to see a watered down
product if I can see these guys doing it?
It has such an extreme level.
I don't really want to watch the smaller
people that car hit as hard with lesser
technique, but you know what I mean? As
I say, nothing to do with gender, but um,
but obviously there's a few exceptions
to the rule and Shevchenko Yon j check
Amanda Nunez. Cyborg. Yes,
definitely. Amazing talent.
There really is just a smaller pool.
It's a smaller fight this weekend,
one sensational [inaudible] and Valentino,
that was a very,
very high level fight. Oh, it really
works. And what it really was. Yeah. Yeah.
And Yon Jake, Jake impress me,
you know, because he had a,
I think it was a tough three
rounds, fourth round. You know,
she probably mad at the age,
that fourth round, you know,
so it's impressive that she,
uh,
we still had the fight in her soul late
in the Florentine is just too strong to
be too good a grappler and yeah.
Yeah. And bigger, physically bigger.
Like you see Europe, we see it. You
can see when their guests each other,
the young Ghx very slim,
very slender,
and she's chef can cause muscle on her
or serve Chanko was successful at one 35
you know,
it's a big gap between 35 and one 15 were
you on the reason young and JJ went up
to one 25 is because she couldn't get a
boat back at one 15 and I say that with
the absolute great. So respect,
you know, uh, when I was,
a lot of it was the week it was crushing
her and then she didn't have to cut
weight for one 25 but the, on the
flip side, you're fighting a bigger,
stronger woman. Sure. Valentino, exactly.
If she was fighting another
Shoreway up to one 25 yeah,
maybe things will be different,
but that, that was always on paper.
A bad matchup.
Yes. I agree. My opinion, yeah,
it went down the way I thought it was
going to go save here. A lot of fights,
but the main event, man, the main event
was one of those fights where I was like,
I don't know. I don't know.
[inaudible] I was like, if Max, uh,
and if it goes to the ground and max
gets caught up in something, I mean,
or tag has got the nastiest
fucking submissions in that.
Absolutely. Yeah. I mean, I did it
now. I mean, as a sad, I favored Max.
I thought Max was going to do it,
but it as well,
there's just something
about Brian Arteaga. I mean,
just, just looking at him,
he looks like a fucking killer.
You know what I mean?
And he'd say clear the division. He's
calm. He has that presence, you know?
I don't know.
He has it.
He has just going to look on his face
that it wants to snap your neck off.
He's going to learn. He's going to
learn from that fire. Of course. A Lot,
a lot going on in that fight to learn
from it. Yeah. In terms of his movement,
in terms of just trying to handle Max's
barrage and it's the pressure that he
puts on you.
Well,
he's only young,
so that should be a massive motivator
for him because when you go away and you
win fires, he's great. There's no
better feeling than winning fights.
And I'm telling you this like you
don't know, but you know this.
But you know when you went in fights,
he's great and you go and you don't really
change anything because everything's
going good. You know, but when you
lose, then you're like, okay shit,
I don't want to make a habit
of this was the undefeated,
I think it was undefeated.
That was his first loss. So
now he's going to say, okay,
what can I do to it to ensure that
I don't start getting more losses?
You know,
he wants to be the champion.
Like my first loss was to Rashad
Evans and then I remember on the day,
um, Dave, the way in,
he was a sat in the sauna killing himself
during his usual thing and the team
that I was with that shall
remain nameless back then,
they'll want it to eat Chinese food.
So I was like trying to order the
most healthiest thing in the Chinese
restaurant that I could.
So I was eat eating noodles
and drinking fucking sprite,
you know,
on the day of the Wayne,
she's as crazy cause cause when I was at
two oh five, I didn't cook way at all,
you know, so I remember, um, you know,
and I still weighed in another time when
I fought hell of a synthetic world back
in the day,
it was my first fight at Manchester and a,
I was getting tickets for
everybody, you know, loving it,
really loving the attendees were
first time, you know what I mean?
So get your tickets,
talking about a fucking pain in the ass.
It was a lot of tickets is a
pain in the ass. Oh my God.
Because you've got to get
the money off the people,
then you've got to get the ticket,
then you've got to do the transaction.
This is day of the fight.
You know what I mean?
I remember being on my knees there,
the fight,
we've hundreds of tickets and cash
everyone. I'm like, Oh my God,
why did I do this? Oh no, sorry. The
day, the way in part of me anyway.
And I was so stressed out
with it and I drove home.
I fell asleep in my own
bed now before the night,
before the night before the way,
pardon me. And I'm driving home and uh,
I was so stressed out and I was hungry.
I hadn't eaten all day because
I forgot I was too stressed.
And as I'm driving along the freeway,
I don't really eat burger king,
but I saw the sign for Burger King
and I was starving. I thought fuck it.
So I pull off and I get a triple whopper
with cheese and bacon fries and a large
coke.
And I'm sitting there and you know the,
the noise that it makes
when you get to the bottom,
that sound as asthma.
Oh what am I doing?
Holy Shit.
Cause I'm so stressed out with a God damn
tickets I'd forgot all about it is all
that crap.
So before did I just stepped on the
scale? No problem. I'm with Rashad Evans.
Same thing. I just stepped on the
scale. So after that I was like, okay,
what can I change? Well, I'm not making
the sacrifices I could be, you know,
to be as successful as
possible. So that was, you know,
moved out of the middle away and Ortega,
you know, he's not going to drop weight.
He does not need to, but he doesn't need
to. You can work on some things, you know,
you can learn simple as that.
Yeah. He most certainly
can. I mean, uh, he's uh,
he's got tremendous Jujitsu and his
boxing is very good as well. But you know,
when you experienced
that kind of a fighter,
when you experienced that kind of
a champion, like Max Holloway, you,
you understand that there's,
there's areas where you're exposed,
there's areas where you have holes and
you have areas where you can't compete
with him. And as successfully as you
have been with previous fighters.
So it's a learning experience and I'm
sure he'll be better because of it. Yeah,
I would say because of the third
round then. Yeah. You know,
he's surely made it competitive in the
third round and landed a couple of good
shots. Cause I was going to say, you know,
in some circumstances it doesn't matter.
You go where work your ass off,
you're never going to beat that guy.
Right. You know what I mean? All the work,
all the culture. You spend all the
money and dedicate your fucking life.
God live in a monastery in fucking China.
Do whatever you want.
You're never going to be that guy.
But in the third round he kept him
on as he landed some good shots.
So I wouldn't say that's necessarily
applicable. Um, you know,
but it certainly got to do
some work. Yeah. He's in the
striking department. Yeah.
Yeah.
And the striking department and I'm sure
in the wrestling department as well.
Sure. You know, he got him down briefly,
but Max did a fantastic job of a stuffing.
It getting back up to his feet,
you know, a retaining, you know.
Yeah, for sure. I mean, I don't
want to speak out of turn. Um,
I did find it somewhat curious. Is it
Hannah grace here? Yes. Hannah. Grace,
you've given him the, the, the, the, the,
the boxing advice in the corner. Yeah,
I find that somewhat curious.
Yeah. You know, when I,
when I had my FYS Jason Parillo
off the fire was on the fee,
he was given the instruction. When the
fire hit the floor, Brady frank took over,
you know, and if there
was elements, you know,
they knew their elements in the corner,
you know, he'd say his bit, boom, you go,
you know, no disrespect to had a
grace. He's done amazing things.
You've been a tag of by the, by everything
I see online, you know, congratulations.
You know,
but when you get now struck,
I don't really want advice from his
shit to coach. Right. All right.
No, that's a good point. It's a
very good point. You know, um, it's,
it's interesting.
Like you,
you had a great situation with Jason
Parillo and the other coaches that you
worked with, and sometimes a young
fighter needs like a mastermind, right?
Matt Hume or a for Rasa.
Someone who could put it all
together for you at John Crouch.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, absolutely. And I
was also going to say,
and this is probably well by all accounts,
it is what Henry is to always take
a mentor as well. He does see my,
he's as mentor. So for that, you know,
maybe I shouldn't have quiet set
it in the words that I did use,
you know what I mean to say is that
that is his mentor, his father figure,
whatever it is.
So there's a reason why he is there,
but for sure bring on an expert
in those areas of specialist.
Yeah, yeah. It's uh, you
know, so it's a crazy world.
The world of fights
in mixed martial arts, you know what
I mean? As I said, there's a lot of,
there's a lot of fakes.
Well, there's a lot of that and
there's a lot of, it works good now,
but then when you find a world
class fighter, you realize why,
why there was holes in that.
Yeah. That you'll find out pretty quick.
You know, when you've got a coach,
there's never,
now you don't have to have real life
combat experience to be a good coach.
But it helps. It certainly helps. It.
It helps the fighter really trust the
advice that they're giving you. Yeah.
For a fire to be standing there
and telling you throw combinations.
Have you ever been in there?
You have experienced what it's like to
have another guy trying to take your head
off every time and you're,
and you're going to talk shit to me.
Did you see the Mike Perry
video now planning my Peri
Peri is great video or did
he do
bill telling him that like, like when
you're fighting and the coach is like, go,
go, go, go, go. He's like,
I'm not trying to get fucking
hit right now. Yeah, exactly.
That's what is video too.
I know
Mike, you know he's an intense guy
and he's talking about, and he's like,
we're faking, we're faking, were
fainting. We're trying to make our way in,
but no one wants to make a move because
no one wants to get clipped first.
Yeah. Well, I remember, you know,
I mean when I fought Rashad Evans,
it wasn't the most action packed fight.
And when I watched it back I was like,
fuck, why did I just go for it a
little bit more? And then I'm like,
oh cause I remember,
cause every time we took a step forward,
built the wind of the punches nearly
taking my head off when you sit,
even myself, when you sit and
watch and go, wow, I do more.
But then you take yourself back to when
you were in there and you know, ah yeah,
that was why that was why,
you know,
to such a tricky situation
and the fight game evolves,
the styles evolve in the way guys
pursue fights, evolves. It's just,
it's really interesting to watch know
you see a guy like mighty mouse who does
things different than anybody else.
And you go,
oh well look at how this motherfucker does
it. You know what I mean? No, for sure.
And it's, it's a, it's
a sport where, you mean,
you were incredibly fortunate in that,
um,
you got to not just be
there when it was exploding,
but you've got to got to be a part
of the explosion. Sure. You know,
I mean, that's not, I absolutely, I made
six. You were, you were
in the ultimate fighter.
Yeah. 2005. I feel like it was
December, 2005. Yeah. Yeah. Crazy,
right? Crazy man. It
really was. It really was.
It was good times when it
was just popping. Oh yeah.
I remember when the ultimate
fighter first came out.
I know it was on Bravo TV in England.
Oh, Sam's here. And I said to my wife,
I was like, check this out. And she's
like, I can't watch it. I'm like,
why is it because if you are on
there, you'd win the things. Right.
I don't want to watch it. It's not
fair, Michael. You should be on there.
And then Lo and behold, you
know, about six months later,
they were looking for
two English men. And, uh,
we went down to Earl's court for
auditions. And the great thing was,
at that time I was 10 and now
I was the cage rage champion,
cage warriors champion in FX three
champion as well as the British headwear
kickboxing champion as well.
And every 100 that was auditioning
for the light everywhere.
I'd knocked them all out in
the first round. Of course,
you know, to, to my style.
I Made, you know, Dana fully
aware of that. But uh, yeah,
it was crazy, man. I couldn't
believe it. You know, it was nuts.
I'd never been to America.
Next minute I'm on some fucking we TV
show and a manager in Las Vegas, you know,
it was, it was a great
time. It was, it really was.
What was it like being separated from
your family for six weeks and doing that
show?
And
very hard, very difficult. Of course.
But I was there for a reason,
you know,
so I was the greater good, you know,
I said, yeah, of course it sucks.
It sucks being away. Sucks, missing time,
missing birthdays, all that type of stuff.
But if you're doing it for a
reason, then, then you know,
he's gotta be mature about it. My wife
always was, the kids understand, you know?
Yeah. It's not good being
away from home, but, uh,
I'm working on something here and I
just set us up. Come on, do me a favor.
Understand, you know, well, it worked out.
Yeah. They were always great, you know.
Yeah. It worked out and then it did
not. No regrets. I mean, maybe a few,
maybe a few.
Yeah. But you know what, man,
there's no way to not have him. Yeah.
I mean there's no perfect path.
That's one of the crazy things about
fighting zig when you should a zag.
Do you get hit? That's it. There's
no, that's part of the game.
That really is the sport.
You know, it's, uh,
it's such a cliche thing to say
so many ways to win and lose,
but there really is, you know, and as
you say, Zig when you should have zagged,
the smaller gloves, you know, the
take downs, that's the problem.
When you find a restless, such
a pain in the ass, you know,
cause I'm a better strike is
the most of these west is.
But when they tried to take you down,
it changes everything because
you go out and you're like,
okay this motherfuckers just try to take
me down. That's all he's trying to do.
So I can stand here and I'm going to wait
for him to shoot and then I'm going to
stuff his take down because
I'm waiting for a take down.
I'm not thinking about the hands and
Douche. Then you get caught with a shot,
you know like what the fuck he
supposed to be gone for a take down,
not punching me in the face.
And then all of a sudden you're striking
is terrible because you're totally
thrown off by the wrestling. So it, it,
it's, it's a very, very difficult spoil.
It really is.
Another one of your most impressive
victories was the second fight with Dan
Henderson cause you got hit with some
fucking oh yeah. Arms in that fight.
But you refuse to go out. Yeah. You
refuse to be stomped in that fight.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
That was a,
that was a display of willpower and a
lot of ways because I remember watching
those,
those big shots from Henderson land
and I mean they were on the edge.
I mean,
you were on the edge going out.
Oh, for sure. Absolutely. I mean,
I remember he hit me, I went down,
it was swarming on me, hit me with some
elbows, but I remember I was always fine,
but I was like, Holy Shit. You
know, that was what hit me there.
And then I managed to get myself back
to mafia and had blood pouring down my
face and whatnot. Of course, second round,
the same thing happened and he had two
big mamas in the file too. Big shots.
But they were big moments. But you
don't win a 25 minute five by London,
two shots, you know. But they were
big shots. Fair play to him. But uh,
you know, I refuse to quit
there because, you know,
obviously going into that fight,
I talked to me the shit like always,
and you can lie to everybody. You can lie
to the media. You can lie to the press,
you can lie to your family.
Lighty coaches was not necessarily lies,
but you can ooze bravado and this and
that. But you can't lie to yourself.
You know, when you let him bed at night
and your head's on the cushion, you know,
can't bullshit yourself,
you know,
and day of the fight because the
fire was at six in the morning.
They're the fight.
I'm let them my bed trying to just have
a nap cause it was going to be a long
night obviously.
And uh,
I couldn't sleep and all I
was thinking human nature.
Last time I stepped into
an octagon with this guy,
I was fucking out cold for a long time.
My brain was scrambled eggs for a
long time after that fight. And, uh,
as I say,
you can lie to everybody else,
but now the fight was getting close and
it's in my hometown and it's my first
title defense and all this.
I'm like, Shit, Shit. I know
I'm better than this guy,
but fuck, last time, last time it
didn't end well. So, uh, I was, uh,
getting a little worked up and I remember
I was at the arena and I was kind of,
you know,
being a little edgy,
a little snappy with people
and there's not need for it.
And then I just stopped over.
I started laughing and I said,
what's you laughing at? I said, well,
what's the worst it's
going to happen if I lose,
what's the word I'm going to lose a fight?
It's happened before,
so why am I stressing myself out of it?
And I just started laughing after that.
It was fine, but uh, yeah,
yeah, no, it was, uh,
I definitely, uh, had a sour face the
next day after that one for sure. Yeah.
But you, you know, you got
through the fire. Yeah,
no I did and I felt great.
The only problem was in the fifth round
because this cheekbone, it's swollen.
It was on my good side. It's shad, the
cheekbone on the, on my good side and a,
it swelled up so much I could
hardly see out of that eye,
this size Fox as well.
So in the fifth round,
I'm like trying to like get a certain
angle where I could even see the,
do you know what I mean? It was a
nightmare, you know? But uh, yeah.
Got The job done unfortunately.
Is there anything that like is on the
horizon in terms of like medical science
that you're looking at in terms of
being able to fix your eyes? Eh,
not that I know of. I spoke to
doctors about it, you know, cause I,
I was uh,
yeah,
I was always curious what, what,
what, uh, what could be done.
But I don't think in my lifetime there is,
but the reason I retired was that the gas,
Dylan five,
because I was clear to fi and
the doctors were always like,
we don't really advise it,
but you are cleared.
You've passed the test just
by the skin of your teeth.
And for me that was all well and good.
You gotta do your medical.
The most stressful part of
all of that was when you,
you got to got to do a full training.
Come now,
then fly somewhere and you're going
to see another doctor, a commission,
docs read the way it right.
And you don't know what this
doctor is going to be like.
You don't know if he
knows anything about eyes.
You don't know if he wants to be a hero.
You don't know if he wants to make
fucking press the guy that pulled the main
event. Do you know what I mean?
Very, very stressful time. So for me,
the fight was always the easy part.
The hard part was just fucking making it
to the octagon and I got to the Wayne's
and I get cleared up. The feeling was
like, okay, we're good. The fights aren't,
because I didn't know the fire was on
until I got past the commission. Doctor.
How many different fights did
you have to go through like that?
About 12 something like that.
Fights with,
I'm not sure as as 12 something like that.
Oh Damn
Belcher. Kang Lee Belcher. Tim Kennedy.
Kung Lou Rockhold CB tells lies.
And this is silver.
Luke Rockhold,
Dan Henderson,
GSP gasoline. 11 1111 yeah. Yeah.
So that was stressful. And
then obviously, you know,
I lost the belt and I would in
my mind, every tired, you know,
I just hadn't made it formal yet. And, uh,
I was driving up for lunch
with my wife and my in laws,
they were in town and we heard on the
Sirius Xm fight club dilute Thomas show.
He was talking about,
and this is Silva silver testing,
positive for steroids and they
needed a replacement. And I said,
should I do it? And they were
like, what are you talking about?
So I text Dana right then and there,
and then a week later I'm on a plane to
Shanghai, no training, I'd done anything.
I'm like, well, I mean, I trained as
soon as I found out about that, you know,
I mean, I, you know,
I aspire it a few times and then got on
a plane and went out there and, uh, yeah,
you know, God bless him. He got
me. But then after the fight,
because you know, as I said, you
know, I was cleared to fight,
but the doctors always said,
we don't recommend it because if
anything happens to you, good eye,
you're going to, you're going to be in
a real problem. And I was like, well,
so many fighters in the UFC have long
careers and they don't get detached
witness. Okay. It's, it's,
it's a very, not rare,
but it's pretty rare. Pretty read or
hear about it too much when I'm thinking,
okay, well the strike, the
lightenings already struck. Okay,
lightening isn't going to strike twice.
You know what I mean?
I'm not that fucking unlucky anyway.
So we have the gas in them fight and
then we go to an after party in Shanghai.
I mean some club and a,
I'm in the club and every time I look
that way and he still does it to this day,
every time I look that way,
like a bolt of lightening,
like I'm slouching around
when you do that. Yeah. Work.
What do you see? Was it art?
Someone's taking lasher yeah.
Yeah.
And I was in this club and every time
I'm looking at it's doing that and,
and I start freaking out, cause
I know you, I've got history of,
of symptoms with eye problems and
whatever. And I start telling myself,
I don't believe this. I've got a
detached retina in my good eye and I'm,
I'm freaking out. And, uh,
I didn't want to be in a nightclub around
a bunch of fucking dickheads anyway or
drinking. I hate nightclubs. So, um,
I said I'm just going to go to the
toilet and a restroom. And, uh,
that was it. I was leaving, you know,
but I just wanted to be by myself and I
left there and shed a little tear in the
taxi.
I didn't want to be sat in the fucking
nightclub crying because if people see me
crying, they're gonna blow. He's crying.
Cause bless him, he lost a fight to gas.
Dillon was like,
no,
I'm not crying cause I lost a fight to
gas them crying because I might be going
fucking blind here. You know what I
mean? So, uh, so I jump in a taxi,
I got back to my hotel and then a layer
on Perillo and a few guys came back,
see if I was okay and you know,
whatever.
We just carried on talking and having
a few drinks at the room and forgot all
about it. And uh, you know, I'll turn
into a bit of a messy one in Shanghai,
forgot all about my eye and the next
thing I'm on a plane flying home and I'd
forgotten all about it.
I fall asleep on the plane.
I wake up halfway home problem
flying over the Pacific somewhere,
the planes pitch black and then albums,
he starts doing it again. I'm like, Shit,
because I've forgotten all about it.
So trying to get a Wifi on the plane,
trying to find something about it,
trying to Google it, what it could be
and all the rest of it. And the wife,
I would at work and I'm going off on him
trying to beg the air hostess, you know,
please, please do I need to get a Wifi?
I need, I have to. I didn't tell her why.
And she said, nice, it's down right
now. And I'm like, Oh fuck. Anyway,
so our land there, call my eye doctor
straight away. I tell him, I said, listen,
I think I've got a detached retina
and her good eye. Why'd he say that?
Tell them the stories is don't worry,
don't worry. You know, he'd be okay.
So I go see an eye doctor the
next day. And uh, he says, well,
I told him the issue and he says, why do
you say that? And I tell him why. I said,
so do you think it's a detached
retina? And he says, well,
it certainly sounds like one.
I'm like, fuck me. He says, okay,
we're going to put some drops in your
eyes. Everything's going to go blurry.
And I only see a tiny bit out this
eye. And I'm like, ah, I made,
I make stupid joggers. My
defense mechanism on like, oh,
I guess a better get used to this view
way, Huh? And the doctor's like, well,
we don't know that just
yet. And I'm like, fuck me.
Do you know that's not the answer
I was expecting anyway. Turns out,
didn't have a detached retina. I had a
partial vitreous detachment. So you have,
you,
you're a cornea here,
you retina at the back and in
between what's called bitchy fluid,
millions of fibers connect to
the retina to send a message.
I think if I'm getting it
wrong, I'm sorry, doctors.
And in your sixties that
just slides off the retina,
detaches naturally. Maybe you 60,
70, who knows? But as you get older,
through old age, it just slides
off. It can detach due to trauma.
So that's what happened to me. Uh, so it,
it, it, but it had partially detached.
So, but the problem was when
these fibers are polling,
they can cause the retina to tear. So,
uh, they were, they were like, well,
we need to keep an eye on this and
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. So anyway,
long story short, after that, I thought,
fuck this. Yeah, they ain't worth it.
And if they've done anything to the
isense no, and there's nothing to be done.
There's nothing that be done. Nothing
can be done now. Yeah. And, and,
and they're fine with it.
They're happy with it. It,
it's okay. But it, but it was,
for me it was, it was, uh,
you know, a step too far.
I pushed it as far as I, you know, I was
willing to push. In fact, I'm a liar.
I was at a spouse to fight with shard
in London earlier this year, but, uh,
we couldn't agree on the deal
terms with the UFC fight.
Never materialized.
And I was flying up to New York to
do my podcasts. We've Louis and, uh,
on the plane I'm watching this movie
called the journeyman and Paddy Considine.
It's about a boxer.
He's a world champion at the end of it,
it wins a fight and then he has
severe brain damage and it's a very,
very sad movie. She checked it out. It's
really, really powerful. Very, very good.
Anyway, I watched that in a
fudge. That's it. That was it.
So I'm going to have the plane. We
started our podcast. I said boom.
I wouldn't even ask him.
What's it good for you? I,
it was the best decision I ever
made. You know, I've been very,
very happy ever since.
Yeah. You, I mean, you have other options.
I mean, you had a long, great career.
You have options.
Yeah. I mean, as I say, no
regrets, you know, I mean, um,
it, it was a wonderful ride.
I, I loved it. I, I never thought
a young kid doing martial arts and,
and you know,
a guy that liked to have a scrap when
he was a kid could take it this far.
And that's a beautiful thing about
the UFC these days. You know,
if you're up that certain mindset,
that certain character you
like a bit of rough and tumble,
you don't mind getting a punch in the
face here and there and you're willing to
go for it. You can make your living, you
can make it, you know, when I was younger,
I used to do a lot of
professional kickboxing,
but I had never looked at it as a
career because it wasn't back then.
But now it's great. You know, it
really is a career viable career.
Well, especially for a guy
like you who's a good talker,
who understands how to break fights
down and you can make this transition.
It's one of the things that are really
like about the UFC and they've allowed
these fighters, like, you know,
I do a lot of commentary now with Paul
Felder and Daniel Cormier, Dominick Cruz,
and they've given these guys,
he's,
Oh yeah, it's great. Yeah,
as I was saying before,
but that was one of the things that scared
me as well as a kid because your gyms
all over the world and you see amazing
talent everywhere. Amazing talent.
And you know, the, the, the,
the sleeping in the cars
or the sleeping on a couch.
It's someone's friends
house, you know, and,
and they're struggling to pay the bills
and the jab and a shitty beat up piece
of Shit, you know? And it's a shame.
And I see them and in my heart goes
out to them and for whatever reason,
they don't get the breaks.
They'd all look right.
The cop put it together and find out
the nerves get the better of them.
Who knows what it is. But they just don't
it. You know what, I'm fine. Such a cruel,
vicious sport. It really is. So that's
why when people, I get asked all the time,
do you want your son to
do it? I might. Well, no,
not really the way icees I
fall so he doesn't have to,
but if he wants to use the number for
frank wrestler in, uh, in California,
he's seen the videos, he's a CEO.
He's a beast. If he wanted to,
of course I support it.
My father supported me ridiculously.
If it wasn't for my father, I
wouldn't be here either. Um,
but I wouldn't wish it on him.
I would've wished to life of a fire on
anybody because it's so unpredictable and
just because you're good and just cause
you can take a punch and just cause
you're, you're an animal in there doesn't
mean you're going to be a success.
You know what I tell you
got to be the perfect storm.
What I tell young fighters is, uh,
you know, when they say, Oh, I'm,
I'm thinking about trying MMA, I go, don't
do it. Yeah. If you're thinking about it,
don't do it.
If you tell me you're obsessed with it
and you want to be a world champion,
then I say go ahead. Sure, absolutely.
Yeah. If you're not obsessed,
there's some motherfuckers out there
that, oh yeah, they're living at 24,
seven all day long. They're
there and this is a thing. Um,
you know,
you see a lot of young fighters now,
they're obsessed with the image
and you know, you know what I mean?
Cause it's on TV. It's cool and
it's got a lot of popularity now,
so a lot of people want to do it. As
I said, this pretenders in coaches,
it's pretenders in fires as
well. A lot of people, you know,
they want to be in,
are they want to be Connor Mcgregor,
they want to be choked with Ella,
whatever,
and they're all fucking way and tap
out and we're having Mohawks and stuff.
Do you know what I mean?
And they're talking about,
or for this camp I'm going to
bring in this guy fucking camp.
You don't have training camps at the
start of your career, right at the start,
he clear you.
When you train Monday to Friday,
you have a fire at the weekend if you,
when you're back in the gym fucking
Monday. You know what I mean?
You fight every few weeks. You know,
every, you know, when I was starting,
and I think I had six fires in the first
year, probably five kickboxing fights.
You're trying to build momentum.
You're not doing camps right.
I don't want to hear any young
fire saying to me for this camp,
I'm focusing on my wrestling.
He's like, shut the fuck up.
You've had two amateur fights. You're not
doing the trading category. Do Training.
That's it. You know, for
sure. Well, listen, Mike, uh,
thanks for doing this,
man.
I'm going to flash it and we could do
it again anytime you learn. Yeah, no,
I don't tell everybody about your podcast
with Louis Gomez. She, yeah. To Louis.
Yeah, absolutely. The big shout Lewis, I
think he's listing all areas guide. Oh,
hilarious. Absolutely
hilarious. I believe you. Me, uh
Oh, that shit. Yeah. Youtube on their
macro Bisbing podcast. I believe you,
me podcasts, iTunes, all that crap,
check it out or don't, you know,
don't give a fuck if you like it.
If you love what I've said for the last
hour to check it out, if not, kiss my ass.
Thank you brother. Thank you. Lose German.